foreign
starting the work session you're right
great all right so um
no no I I yeah
so uh I'm gonna try to I thought might
be the easiest way to go through this
would go be to go through provision by
provision
um so what I sent you and I think this
is the easiest way to kind of track
what's going on I find it to be easier
than with all the
in the format that they that they give
you all the numbers and everything on
the bill
um I thought it would be easier just to
go through Section by section it's a
little easier to read on the the what I
sent to you which is the which has the
xB sb60
what was the passed uh by the Senate and
it also has some amendments that were in
the letter that I had uh brought to you
last week so I thought that this might
be the easiest way to go through and so
what I thought what I would do is kind
of just go Section by section
explain what's going on here and then we
uh if you have questions and then the
the rules piece fortunately isn't until
the end it's the last provision so um
but I think uh representative
um mcgu brought up some really good
points about rules versus statutes and
so I'm going to talk about that as we go
through because I think his point was
that stuff that's important should be in
statute
and I wholeheartedly agree and I think
what you'll see here is that most of
what we're doing is actually putting
stuff in statute that was important so
so I don't think that there's anything
else other than the last provision that
is actually dependent on rules
so um I I just want to but we'll go
through that I think as we go through
because I think that that was a it was a
really good point that he made and I
want to make sure that we we capture
that as we go because he's not here
today
um so the first section is called
enforcement of classification
and what this does and I I tried to
explain this a little bit in testimony
but but I'll just sort of review
anything that's a big Federal project
requires a big Federal permit requires
the state to do this fed this 401
section 401 certification which is
certifying that it'll meet our state
water quality standards so that's all
that is this is the section of law that
authorizes the department to do those
401 certifications which are which are
part of the federal Clean Water Act so
that's what you're seeing here that's
section one is really that part
the the addition here that's in sb60 is
that it gives the department the ability
to waive a 401 certification currently
the only thing we can do is approve it
or deny it we can approve it with
conditions or approve it approval
conditions or deny it we don't have an
opportunity to waive it the federal
Clean Water Act has the option that the
state can waive a 401 certification
I think I gave the example last time of
Portsmouth where they had a water pipe a
replacement of a water pipe that's not
it's not really impacting anything but
it happens to go through that happens to
go through tidal waters so it requires
an Army Corps of Engineers individual
permit therefore it requires a water
quality certification
it essentially has no impacts there's no
re other permitting required it has
ample public ability to to weigh in
because it's a federal permit that's a
project that we would waive
certification on saving them the city uh
money uh in terms of getting Consultants
to write their applications and all that
stuff and our staff uh which we already
have a pile of work of trying to deal
with that so we would be able to waive
that kind of certification that's the
kind of projects we're talking about
here so that's provision number one any
great so that one I think is pretty
straightforward
the second uh provision
um is about putting into statutes some
time limits for EPA for Des to act
and how and and for the public to have a
clear expectation of the timing of doing
these 401 certifications
currently there is nothing in statute
about timing zero nothing not a word
um and the problem with that is then the
absence of us specifying in statute
what uh
what the time frames are there is a
standard for the state that tells all
agencies that if you have to act on
something you have to do it in 60 days
that's basically there's another statute
that says that
and so we would have to apply that to
this exercise and these are
extraordinarily large complex projects
so this basically puts together a
process where people have some
understanding of what the time frames
involved of going through this process
with the state are
that's all that this project that's all
that this is doing in section two
and
section four section two and four mirror
each other they are just two different
parts of
that enabling legislation that allows
Des to do these 401 certifications
so it has to sit in both sections yes
all right
you have a question
oh
Mr dearest does uh section 401 or does
it does the federal government establish
any time limits yeah so let me talk
about that for a second because I think
this is really important
the Clean Water Act says that all 401s
will be done in no more than one year
so the federal Clean Water Act sets one
year
but what happens as what the federal
rules say is that when an application
comes in
the the federal agency who is in charge
of that particular project
has to set a reasonable time period that
cannot exceed one year
so there are some agencies that set you
know a reasonable time period at 60 days
there are some that put in a year
all the ferc projects the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission that's what all
the hydro all the hydropower
re-licensing that's going on in the
state if you're in the Connecticut
region all the Connecticut dams Great
River Hydro is going through
re-licensing it's going on right now up
in the Androscoggin uh below uh Arrow
below the arrow Dam Daryl Dam included
there's re-licensing going on in the
baker we've called it Baker eight I love
that it sounds like a gang uh but the uh
the baker eight are eight Hydro
facilities on the baker River so all of
these are going through these these
Federal processes they all have a year
that they go through uh but there are
other agencies that set that
so the way that this is written is sort
of the assumption that it's kind of like
a a year-long process
and the issue that came up and and there
one there are a couple of amendments in
here to address that the issue that came
up in testimony from Dot
was that sometimes a federal agency will
set a shorter reasonable period of time
and if that's the case then Des will
have to act on that we don't want to to
not to deny it simply because we didn't
have enough time
so so the way there are some rule
changes suggested
um in here and I'll Point those out
where they are
that will address that issue of timing
should the federal agency set a
different reasonable period of time than
one year
so that does happen and that's why um
the yellow or the the highlighted parts
of your of the rules the ones that are
great out there those are additions that
we're suggesting to make to address that
very issue that you just brought up
but that's basically how this works it's
it's it's
usually a year
but sometimes it can happen that we have
to go faster than that
that also is one of the reasons why we
wanted to put the waiver provision in is
that should there be a a reasonable time
period which in my mind once if it's 60
days it's an unreasonable period of time
but whatever
um that's what they call it the federal
parlance is a reasonable period of time
if it was short and it looked like we
weren't going to be able to get through
the process we would have the ability to
waive the process so that that project
could move forward
so these and again usually these
projects have ample Federal
opportunities for due process and for
it wasn't Darcy
thank you Darcy speaker thanks for the
question I don't know what the procedure
is here because I have two questions but
um the first is in the proposed
amendment the proposed amendment yeah
you know you talk about
um granting and extension so they can
say hey I'd like another 100 yeah right
it seems reasonable but could it's not
clear if they can keep doing that or if
that's a one-time thing
so that's a great question I think that
would probably be a one-time thing
because we would start to run out of
that one year
I'm wondering if it should be more
explicit in here to say that they can
have a one-time uh 120 day extension
thank you that's great
um so you mentioned the waiver part
um which is in you know uh
three
three a c
e it says there's a wave waiver if the
um
if the certification can't be completed
in a reasonable amount of time right
within the applicable time where the
applicable time is described I guess in
A and B yep
and then it says the certificate shall
be considered waived so
um
help me understand why I shouldn't be
concerned that let's say the Des was
understaffed and they couldn't they get
a wave of these things in and they
couldn't comply with all of them in this
time period that we'd let potentially
um dangerous
projects go through yeah so I think that
that's a really good point and the the
fact of the matter is is that if it's if
it's a very big deal project what Des
does is we request the federal agency to
extend the reasonable period of time
and that is usually granted
so that is certainly one aspect of it
the problem that we have and this I
totally get your point and this is one
of the reasons why we put let's try to
put this stuff in statue
we don't want to set up it's we don't
want to set up a system
that would say if we can't make the
reasonable period of time it has to be
denied
automatically because that makes no
bearing on sort of how again how large
or how potentially impacting the project
was
so
we would have to essentially have some
sort of criteria
for determining whether or not
we we would deny something or not and so
it's it becomes very very problematic
the way that it will work though let's
just let's just play this out a project
comes in
there's not enough time to do uh we're
understaffed whatever we can't get to
the project
um if we don't act on it if we fail to
act on it whatsoever it is deemed waived
by the federal agency
so if we make no action whatsoever it
will be deemed waived and the the agency
will will go and and do the permit in
what time period in the reasonable time
so if we fail to act so the only so the
only way that we would be able to stop
the project at that point would be to
deny the 401 certificate which would
stop the federal agency from moving
um so that would become very problematic
for someone who's a proponent of that
project because they would essentially
be stuck in sort of a limbo
um until it somehow got worked out that
I mean they can definitely Sue right
they can say like you have to the
statute says you have to um you have to
comply within this amount of time and
force a decision if they they really
needed to it seems there would certainly
be provisions and there's also
Provisions within the Clean Water Act
for people to have lawsuits under
various different authorities so there's
there's quite a bit of due process I
think that is available to people should
they feel aggrieved that there's a
to me that like you said these are
complicated cases right
and your lab you're giving the submitter
time to sort of get their stuff together
when you ask difficult questions right
but I don't see that the the department
has the same flexibility
that's if they you know if they get back
this massive dump of documents right
they have you know
um
it's not clear another 50 days maybe
after they get that back to right to act
um I totally understand and appreciate
the need to have to bound it right right
um and to prioritize
but I don't see
in um where you said that you would ask
to ask the federal government for an
extension that that doesn't seem to be
codified here no in fact I mean that's
um
yeah I mean it it generally gets set
right at the beginning of the process
it's almost before this process starts
with that reasonable time period is set
but but how does that align with the
language doesn't this this language bind
you rather than that so so what I would
just let me just uh what one of the
reasons why we're doing this I'll be
honest with you
is to put pressure on the federal
agencies
so that they will match their reasonable
time period to what we put in statute
so right now we have nothing in statute
that says it has to be done by a certain
period of time
the federal agency can set their
reasonable time we have had in the past
hard conversations with federal agencies
so one of the reasons why in fact we are
putting this forward is to put pressure
on the federal agencies to match our
statutory language
and that again there's going to be some
Provisions in here which would allow us
to make a faster decision if we have a
project that has a shorter reasonable
time period
and the the fortunate thing is is that
the vast bulk of our work work the work
you know load for 401 certifications are
the ferc processes so that's our vast
vast majority of our load those are all
one-year projects those are you know us
those are slow burn that are coming down
the road we know that those are going on
the other ones that come up we can jump
on so it's it has not at this point
we've not had a resource issue
uh with trying to make sure we hit a
reasonable period of time
the issue that we've run into if there
has been one has really been about
making sure that
um that we had enough information to be
able to make a decision it hasn't really
sure
was there did you have another aspect of
that
uh
normally I uh you know seeing a hearing
you you always come back and for you
there's no back and forth the lounge go
through the chair each time with a work
session you're a little more
loosey-goosey yeah you if you get a
if you got a point that you that there's
a value
uh that you know I will allow a uh
a back and forth a conversation until
you get as you so you can get your
question answered to your satisfaction
uh to it to a point obviously but uh so
just for those of you if you see me
letting it letting it go a little bit
longer or a little back and forth go
that's
I would normally do just because this is
a a work session is more
uh is not it's formal it's to get
information that's really what we're
doing
okay representative harp for a question
or a Yeah question uh thank you Mr deers
first I notice in your highlighted
amendments it says shall so I wanted to
make sure that you wanted shall not May
to Grant an extension
and the other question I got is there's
no time period for the amount of the
extension so if I'm an applicant and I
apply you have to give me an extension
but it doesn't specifically say how long
it doesn't say up to a year it doesn't
say up to six months and if I'm looking
at the statute and I'm talking to your
department you might say to me well it
doesn't say how long give you a week I
give you two weeks do you think we ought
to codify how long the extension can be
good for it's a great question I think
it's a great question I think the
problem that we run into is that is is
this idea of this reasonable period of
time by the federal agency is that it
depending on where we are in the process
at that point
we could be if we extend it if we can't
extend it Beyond when we have to make a
decision so there has to be some
flexibility on how long we would extend
that
um so I think that that's where we would
be able to say you you know somebody
would request a 30-day extension we give
them a 30-day extension if somebody
asked for six months we wouldn't be able
to because that would be beyond the end
of our decision by Clean Water Act
standards Beyond a year so I think that
we would probably need to have some
flexibility in that I'm not sure how we
won't ask for follow-up because he says
I don't need to do that so um if you say
an extension uh for a period of time no
greater than the time required to decide
a decision by the Clean Water Act or
something and then you don't put a year
in case they amend that as the same may
be amended so I know you can't give me
10 years right to finish the project
just looking so yeah we're talking about
time frames and codifying it I thought
it would be nice if we could codify the
extension that's great let me let me let
me think about that if you if that's
okay
um what I'll do is there's a couple of
great ideas uh representative Darby had
a good idea about this sort of one-time
extension
um you know clarifying that I think this
is another good of like how what's that
period of time you could extend it
another good question let me see if I
can come to a conclusion on that and
we'll turn that right around
well
not the contradicted representative
Darby but
there may be times when you grant them a
30-day extension and he needs more time
after that so if you put a limit sure
um can ask for extensions for a period
of times no greater than then it covers
both representative Darby's issue just a
suggestion
yeah I kind of like that maybe we just
put a 30 day in there and then people if
they need more they can just ask for it
and no extensions beyond the time period
needed to arrive at a decision
yeah
representative
thank you Mr chair
um so I'm on
your handout with the revised language
where it says to and I always we're
under B yes and C where it says
notwithstanding sub paragraphs A and B
of this paragraph right the word
notwithstanding is something I always
struggle with and I bet you were
expecting me to say that but so how do
you mean it in this case and is there
another word we could use absolutely so
what I wanted to do
is to the reason why that's in there and
the reason why section F down below are
crossed out
so if you see section these are these
are related these are related issues so
the reason why section in section c it
says the notwithstanding part and it
says in section and F and F is
completely can't crossed out
is to address this very issue that was
raised by representative wrong about
what happens if the federal agencies
require a
if they require a decision faster than
one year or faster than the time periods
allowable Under A and B that's what the
notwithstanding means in that context is
that it's notwithstanding and what
follows that the period of time
specified under Section 401 of the Clean
Water Act which gives the federal
agencies the ability to set a reasonable
period of time so in this case that's
why that the notwithstanding was there
was to address the issue that was raised
thank you the second part of my question
was is there another way to express that
in the amendment I I don't know uh we
can certainly ponder that
um I can take a look at that that
question
um if that's something that it sounds
like that's not a word that uh
it's a word that that that may not be as
concern just that the there's ambiguity
and in my
um career as a legislator and two other
committees we've had
um debates about what the word actually
means and research in certain situations
so I just bring that up because I think
there's something I'm supposed to get
this right okay I just don't okay no I
think it's important that's an important
if I can take um try to answer your
question being an attorney
and writing and not trying to understand
the statutes
I take it as a valid word because if the
items and subsections see
are contrary to the items in sections A
and B you'd have a disconnect and say
what can I do so to clarify C is likely
not equal to a and b so if I'm a judge
and I've got to try to interpret this C
is going to overrule a and b in these
situations so the word notwithstanding
is pretty commonly used in Us in the law
he's in spite of yeah notwithstanding so
it's not contrary so well Mr deers how
do you do c if a and b says this oh well
I don't need to look at a and b in this
situation so it basically eliminates A
and B if you're under C so to me it
makes it pretty clear
I don't know if that helped I'd
thank you that that actually is helpful
to me
um because I I just when you go to look
it up in just a regular dictionary it
can be the word but it can be the word
in spite of
um and I if if
it's a if then
logical question then I just would
prefer that it be expressed in another
way but I am certainly educatable and I
think this is perfectly acceptable is it
but it's almost dead it's always a big
question
so um if I could move along then to
so section three is
um as I re as I said before we have the
section
um in section one we talked about
um this is about RSA 485 a12 3 Roman
three
which is about 401 certifications for
federal projects Roman 4 of that same
provision which is the the what's what
we're talking about this enforcement of
classification is about water
withdrawals
so part of the state statute we have is
that if it's a large surface water
withdrawal we also do the department
does a certification to make sure that
that withdrawal will not cause a water
quality violation
so that's part of state law it's been
that way since I think the 90s at some
point maybe the late 80s
and so we have done these certifications
for large withdrawals
what is a large withdrawal a large
withdrawal is the same definition that
is used for groundwater withdrawals
which is the twenty thousand gallons per
day or 60 000 600 000 gallons over the
course of a of a month
foreign
why this is being put direct so the
currently the statute references another
statute that is part of the drinking
water program
the reason why this is being pulled out
the reason why we're pulling this out at
this point is because for two reasons
one is to separate them in case future
policy makers wanted to actually set
different numbers for those thresholds
because that may be something that we
want to do in the future
the other is to separate out the the
provision that is just about the amount
of water that is what we would classify
as a water withdrawal from other
provisions of that other statute
which includes things like
it includes a number of other things one
of them is diversions I think I
mentioned that when I testified before
we don't really want to have every time
a community wants to move water from one
of their water supply reservoirs to
another water supply Reservoir that
somehow we are considering that a new
withdrawal that would be bad that is
something we don't want to do so we're
taking that word out the diversion work
word out
but this this language that that exceeds
20 000 gallons per day or again the
point of that is to make it very
specific in this statute you don't have
to go looking at at other statutes to
determine that and that it's separated
and separable from the drinking water
program should future policy makers want
to have a different standard in each of
those programs so that's a relatively
straightforward proposition but
certainly uh I can I can entertain any
thank you um so Mr deers I I understand
why you remove the word diversion in the
first line because we're really just
talking about the withdrawal diversion
is covered in other areas of the statute
but it still included on
um
the uh two three lines at no it like in
the middle of that paragraph where it
says make commence Department certifies
that the service water withdrawal or
diversion
I think that that probably should be
foreign
yes
not on groundwater groundwater has its
own as you
you have all had those conversations
I think that the very the very just
uttering the words USA Springs makes
great okay so let's move along to
section four section four is mirror of
section two that we talked about before
again and this refers to the same
enforcement classifications
this does not have the notwithstanding
language uh you'll notice because this
is not a federal this is purely state
law this has no Nexus with federal law
so it doesn't ha this really does set up
those
um it really does set up the the time
frames for doing those surface water
permits the surface water withdrawal
certifications and again I like this
idea of us addressing a certain you know
period of time on a Time extension that
seems like a reasonable addition if
that's something the committee liked
that was a good suggestion by
representative harv and I think it meets
representative Darby's
um suggestion
so we'll we'll deal with that there as
well
so that was it that's that's the only
piece of that's number four again is
just setting up in statute
what is the process what are the
timelines so that you would be able to
uh have an expectation of when you would
um
thank you Mr chair
yes so this uh this section c doesn't
include a qualification for waiving the
certification so that's only
um it says you know approvement Denio
extend whereas the other section had
approved waive or deny yep and so that's
because you said this covers state law
so there's not the the
um option state law to waive uh we we it
we this is where we would go if we were
going to do that
um it doesn't have it in the statute
above
so this
yes we have not added that in the
statute above okay so you're not looking
to now I think not because what we would
do in those cases and this is what we
have done in certain cases where
um for example
the
a ski area
wants to expand its snow making
and so but it's a relatively small
withdrawal and it's coming out of a
relatively small water body
and we looked at the statistics and it
said you know it's it's it's not likely
to have an impact
but because there are interests out
there in the world that have
um
you know want to make sure that the
water resources of the state are being
adequately addressed
then we would write a certification but
it would be a very simple one
but it allows the public it allows
anyone agree to be able to then enter
into the process and that's that's why I
think we felt it was
um there is no other provision to do
that whereas in federal law there would
be lots of other Provisions for people
to be able to have other due process I
anyone else
so section five is is actually I think
really easy
um we have no in the statutes there's no
no requirement to have public notice and
public hearings
so that would be something that we would
put into rule I think it's important for
the public to know what's going on
that's sort of transparency in
government and we just don't have a
provision for that so it seemed like a
good time to add that since we had the
hood open and we were tinkering with the
motor
um section six
So currently if you get a large
groundwater withdrawal or if you're part
of the in-stream flow program
which many of you are familiar with
we've talked about that if you're in the
in-stream flow program and we have five
rivers now that are are in that program
then you are required to do water
conservation plans associated with your
water withdrawal whether you're
groundwater if you're a groundwater all
of them do and if you're in surface
water the ones that are in designated
Rivers as well as other ones that that
have other kinds of permits have had to
have water conservation plans
this change in statute makes it clear
that large surface water withdrawals new
ones non-existing ones new ones would
have to be
I would have to have water conservation
plans so as you're probably aware if
you've looked at these water
conservation plans it just requires you
to know how much water you're actually
using
we have a reporting uh there's a
reporting mechanism which has been going
on for many many years it's very
successful
um
and it requires you to make sure you're
not you know unduly wasting the resource
because you know that we we hold the
waters in our in our in our drinking in
our in our surface waters it's very
clear that we hold them in the public
trusts it's up to you and up to me to to
protect the public trust and so these
are public trust resources so there's an
I think an inherent requirement that we
treat them well
as well as we can so that's the nature
of this particular requirement it makes
it clear and it's again it applies to
new things coming online
um and one of the things that's been I
think
interesting to hear from the in-stream
flow program is that people who you
think might not be in favor of it are
because it let sets a Level Playing
Field for any new people coming into a
system withdrawing water the least they
have to play by the same rules so this
is one of those played by the same rules
um
and finally section seven this is where
we get to um this is where we get to
water quality
um 400 class
so
um
the statutes 485 A8 sets into statute
this requirement for the state to
protect water quality under certain
using certain numbers and such
we also have water quality standards
which the other chapter that we were
just talking about also makes us uh has
us do and and is codified in state rule
and approved by the feds as essentially
back in 2018
um there were some folks who were uh not
happy about the way EPA was doing
certain permitting for wastewater
treatment plants and so a couple of
Provisions were put into state law one
of which was about dissolved oxygen and
that was removed last session because we
identified some unintended consequences
of doing that provision
the other one that was put in was this
we have since discovered that that also
caught has some unintended consequences
so I'm going to just work through this
really quickly
um and and try to be careful and with my
language so that's so it's easy to
understand
there's a measurement a statistical
measurement called 7q10
7q10 is a really simple measurement it's
it's simple to say it's a little bit
harder to do the statistics on but
basically if you look if you take all of
the flow information at a particular
site over all the years that we've
accumulated that flow information so
like a USGS gauge
and you look at it and you say across
all of that time period
what's the lowest flow
a lowest flow of a whole week so you
find the lowest flow of a whole week
which week amongst history has had the
lowest flow period
and then you say what's the likelihood
of that happening on a 10-year basis
so it's a statistic it's like a one in a
hundred year storm this is a what's the
likelihood of that really low one week
happening seven days happening in the
course of a year
so it's a statistical measure and the
the reason why it's all it does
basically is says that's really low it's
it's a way of saying boy that's a low
flow and and so that's what this is not
the lowest of low flows but it's a
pretty low flow it happens very
occasionally and it happens under
certain circumstances so that's what
this statistic is
when we do effluent Wastewater effluent
you have this weight you have your
Wastewater Plant it's pumping stuff out
into the river after it treats it
and if it has toxic things in it things
like copper or aluminum or you know
really truly methyl ethyl offals as I
like to call them we have numbers which
say you can't go below that
and they're calculated because there's
dilution in the river what's coming out
of the plant is you calculate it using
what would be a low flow period that
this would be a this would occur because
then those toxics under high flow in the
spring who cares there's so much water
it doesn't matter to the fish but under
really low conditions you have this
concentration of stuff coming out that
could be toxic to fish
that's all well and good everybody's
agreement yeah that's how you do it
that's pretty much standard
the problem was is that we were EPA was
using the same measurement for nutrients
nutrients are not toxic
not nitrogen and phosphorus are not
toxic because all plants need them
but at high levels they become
problematic as you all are aware aware
having the conversations about
cyanobacteria too much nitrogen too much
phosphorus is too much of a good thing
this is where I always make the the the
the analogy that you're hungry you eat
one you eat one hamburger you feel
better you eat 10 hamburgers you feel a
lot worse so it's that sort of too much
of a good thing
so as we went through and looked at how
permitting was done on nutrients there
were some facilities where using a
statistic like the 7q10 was advantageous
to them
and some facilities where it was
disadvantageous to them and what we
learned from that is that different
Rivers have different kinds of behavior
of their flow statistics and it really
depends on the geology and the terrain
so what we did was we worked very
closely with the folks who were not
happy about how EPA was doing this
and we worked with them on the rule set
that I sent around that ruled that one
page of rules
and I'm just going to point your
attention to the rule this is 170502 I
just sent this around this is a draft
so this is where we have in fact
clarified
that there's lots of different methods
that can be used other than 7q10 7q10
could be one of them again because it
could be advantageous for certain
communities
but there are other ways of calculating
that and that's what's laid out here
once this rule goes through and if and
this has been reviewed by the Rochester
has been reviewed by the various
Consultants that have looked at this
this has been well vetted and will be
well vetted through the rulemaking
process
once this goes through that it allows
EPA to write the permits based on
different methodologies
but we want to maintain the flexibility
to use the 7q10 method of doing that for
the communities and places where it
makes sense to do so
that's what we worked through with
Senator gray Senator gray was the
engineer of that provision
he now understands why this is important
for us to now allow for that flexibility
and and other people have now been
convinced I think
um whether you're whether you're a
someone who has a permit or you're
someone who's worried about the water
flow Downstream that we have a variety
of methods that can be used best to be
able to provide communities with the
right method to be able to judge their
Waters and how much effluently can come
out
that it's it's it's it sounds very
complicated at that but really when you
look at it
it really is a flexibility thing for
both the river specific impacts as well
as the the individual facilities that
representative thank you Mr chair uh
just a minor uh issue I have with this
paragraph but I don't know if it's
standard practice of reporting but when
you talk about the E coli per 100 ml
yeah
um
it you know it's specifying 47 and it's
specifying 88. is should the word cells
be inserted there like 47 you know E
coli cells per do we report as cells per
100 milliliters we record as counts okay
the C stands for counts okay sales all
right
because I wonder if should uh
that's why it basically is just saying
that it's based on three samples of a
period of 47 uh coli per 100 milliliters
so it is counting those per milliliters
yep all right so this is the parlance
that's generally used in okay
they don't mention counts it just assume
it's count it is it is the way that the
measure is set up okay all right just
the word count isn't there right and
um it's not a big deal I was just
wondering if that's yes this is the
correct I just want to make sure
everybody said this is the current
status story language this is what's
this none of this is new all of this is
what exists today okay and those numbers
in there just while we're on E coli and
bacteria those are numbers that are come
from EPA guidance okay because they also
talk about out in any one sample unless
naturally occurring right so
is that specified in rule making what
would constitute naturally occurring
let's say because if let's say you have
animals on the side of a surface water
and they're defecating and it's going in
I mean that's going to occur naturally
with let's say certain types of animals
Wildlife that might be there but there
may be other animals maybe domestic
animals that that's occurring and then
would that be considered not naturally
occurring yeah we've gone through this a
fair bit on various different aspects of
this naturally occurring language shows
up a fair bit in clean water stuff
and what we've determined is this sort
of if it was a beaver dam and there was
nothing Upstream and there was just
beavers and their beavers doing their
business that
that's natural okay but say docks on a
beach
if not for the children dropping their
Goldfish crackers on the beach all day
you wouldn't have the proliferation of
geese and Ducks there
we would not really we would not call
that natural because it has that human
influence on those Wildlife okay and
certainly dog walking and other things
um you know we've done DNA ribotyping of
of E coli
and we can you can map that back to the
kind of animals that actually produce it
and I will say that especially in our
Urban waterways dog shows up as a pretty
significant contributor to E coli in our
Waters um just from from domestic pets
okay
is it okay if I go back um do we just
one other question yeah okay
um thank you Mr chair um just regarding
uh section six the rules for
conservation water
um I think I understand that that you're
saying that you're playing you're
applying these rules to the
um the surface water that's what this
does yes
um do you expect a change in the rules
anything else uh on the general
representative Lamontagne
um
so I think the only language we wanted
to change
was the two times where it says upon
written request
um
that we shall Grant we're going to add
one-time extension
or or something it sounds like maybe a
30 days or one time or something like
that it sounds like I'm gonna say one
time of this okay and it says 120 dash
time period but we really wanted to say
100 a day oops word missing thank you
and that's true on both of them yeah and
then we'd say comma not to exceed one
year in both instances okay I think
that's what really it all agreed to let
me um Let me let me get that in in on
electrons on paper
um so to speak and get that back to you
to make sure that it sounds like that's
what people thought we were going to say
does that make sense
representative oh so Mr chairman a
question of oh one thing um so Mr deers
don't forget about the removing the word
diversion yes I got that too yes and um
so the process going forward so Mr deers
is going to make these updated
Corrections
oh okay all right all right and if I
miss something okay yeah cause it uh
right where do we go yeah
are you going to be putting together a
sample uh Amendment
that was that was I think that sounded
like a you're going to be putting
I would put together some sample
language for the committee to consider
yes
and well are you looking at a
a
everything after the uh everything after
the introductory uh sentence in other
words basically a new uh
uh an amendment that is basically a
complete replacement or you're looking
at replacing in there I think it's just
a few and there would be the P the
pieces that are highlighted okay and so
what I will do is I'll do that so you
anyone's name the amendment right uh
in other words if you put something
together
you could put whoever well you put my
name on it they'll just put our name on
okay sounds great thank you very much
right right right right
if I can make a recommendation
um it would be great if Mr deers or the
final language that we agree upon is
replaces everything after the enacting
Clause because I think there's enough
Corrections here that OLS I don't know
about anybody else but I've had to go
back with them for you know a few
Corrections on amendments when it's kind
of a long bill but there's only there's
changes throughout it it so it may be
easier on them and us if they just do a
whole replacement
rather than going through an existing
Amendment or an existing Bill and making
I absolutely agree after what happened
to me in a bill that I had yeah this
year earlier around this year
they
OLS had a new system that they were
rather than doing the everything after
the enacting Clause replacement it was
easier for them to just replace
individual words and sections
try to get try to explain those changes
when you're sitting in that seat
to a group of people who've never seen
the previous
bill before
it's a disaster so yes you do want to
have it
a complete replacement eventually
eventually maybe not the one that comes
in for for us to uh to look at first but
the final bill that the final Amendment
coming in should be in every a
um yes Mr chair I think that would work
best
um because we are looking at an Omnibus
Bill and just trying to work with the
one piece of it and trying to get one
one or two pieces amended but where it's
throughout the bill I think that would
be
absolutely circumvent the kind of
um
roadblocks we could run into great thank
you and also looking at looking off out
also
person who has to
introduced the bill and write the write
the committee report
it's got to have some
it's got to have help doing that that's
your explanation I mean yeah somebody
can go through and listen to what was
said today sure all of the reasons
behind because the reasons are not in
the in the bill
so would you would you like to would you
like me to take a first cut at a blurb
if
absolutely
yeah you bet you bet sure sure I think
long are your how long are your uh your
I want to they finally the the blurbs
can be in this case I think the the
blurb would be probably a a page page so
so we'll just do a quick a little thing
on each section each one to get so that
people read it and say okay that's
reasonable why you're doing it yeah why
wins and wears right simple term yes so
that sure because otherwise
somebody reads somebody reads the bill
they go
is that right right it looks like a lot
um it looks like a lot yeah but it
doesn't have any background to it it
doesn't have any explanation to the
I want to take this opportunity to
comment on that
um and when we are looking at yes the
committee report
we want to not only
um keep it simple but we want to use the
same terminology that we've been using
right along where we are you know we're
blasting science at people and we want
them to be able to understand it and not
feel like we're losing them in the
technical jargon
so there's that part of it and then
there's keeping the facts straight what
I've been using with some of the writing
that I've been doing is putting it into
this online editor app called Hemingway
and you can look on the sidebar it's
just an app you just you you go to it
and you
select your text and you plug it into
this thing and it'll tell you what grade
level and how many
passive verbs it doesn't want you to use
passive verbs which is really hard to
get around in the law but anyway it's
very helpful to give you some feedback
without finding another person to say
hey can you understand this
we'll be sitting here rules
classification
machine and it'll be a machine so
but we want to speak to all of the
representatives and we want to tell them
what we're doing without making them
think that we just sleep in here and
crunch up chemical names
I will uh I'll do my best uh to uh to to
try to capture a uh to try to capture
that voice in there
um
this I do we do do a we do a fair bit of
this and I will I will make sure that
it's it's written in language that
yeah
other than that
do we think we have to meet again on
just to exactly who exactly otherwise I
yeah obviously yeah yep yep I will turn
this right around as quickly as we can
this week
um I'll have something to you on Friday
at the very latest and that will give
you the whole weekend to contemplate 401
certifications
I know that's what I'm gonna do this
weekend
this was very very helpful
um it is a lot for we have 10 new people
on the committee and we really
appreciate your time and attention to
all of us oh absolutely no this is this
is I love you you probably sense this
but I actually very much enjoy this so
wax my hand
we're here
we'll start at 10 30 with our our normal
foreign
okay like to open the hearing well
first I wanted to in that sense regards
this is the first hearing of the the
morning I'd uh like uh to uh you stay
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
indivisible with liberty Justice for
Allah
and Senate Bill 160 and representative
you get a name and I had identity
morning Mr chair and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Peter O'Neill I'm speaking on behalf of
Senator Howard Pearl I am his
legislative aide he's currently in
Senate Edna so this will be a very brief
introduction introduction I won't be
able to take questions on this bill
Senate Bill 160 is relative to the use
of ohrvs on designated trails and
requiring a permit to operate certain
ohrvs from Before Sunrise to after
Sunset the bill prohibits the operation
of ohrvs for recreational purposes on
designated trails and at designated
times two things to note about this bill
is that it was passed as introduced
there weren't any amendments from the
Senate and the effective date of the
bill would be 60 days after passage like
I said unfortunately I won't be able to
take any questions and that is the
introduction for the bill
okay
thank you very much I agree no there's
no need for questions we will get right
into the bill
representing fishing game looks
like seven minutes
good morning you could have eight
my name is Michael Eastman I'm a captain
with the New Hampshire fishing game a
law enforcement Division I am the ohrv
coordinator for Enforcement Education
so this bill is a two-part uh or speaks
on two issues that we have heard from
our constituents about
um that is uh the first being
prohibiting uh the use of ohrvs that are
registered as street vehicles and what
that is uh it speaks to an issue with
the issuance of a quad recycle plate in
the state of Montana so what happens is
that individuals can seek out a a
attorney's office in Montana which
creates a LLC on that LLC then allows
them to register their uh UTV as a
quadricycle in that state which then uh
under a motor vehicle law allows
reciprocity between states and then they
therefore can operate it on roadways as
a motor vehicle so
uh it during the summer I had meetings
with Department of Motor Vehicle about
this issue it was uh constituents were
coming to me and saying that this was
really putting a black eye on the ohrv
community whereas
um and the and state law enforcement
really had no way to speak to this issue
um with these vehicles that are titled
as off Highway recreation vehicles being
operated on roadways so what this
portion of the bill would do is it would
allow certainly if DMV
wants these on the road that would be
for them to then come up with some sort
of legislation to to prohibit that but
on our side of fish and game we would uh
ask that that they if they are
registered for the road then that's fine
but that's where their use would be
limited to so therefore what this would
do is that if they are registered under
this Montana plate or or any of
registration outside of a special
commercial plate which could only be
used for agricultural or light
Industrial in this state and that plate
is issued by Department of Motor Vehicle
that it could not be registered if
outside of that for recreational use so
if they so choose to spend the money get
this Montana plate operated on the
roadway they could not then use it
recreationally on the trails so that
would really be that portion of
of the bill the second portion is uh the
uh expanding our special event permit So
currently anyone seeking to have a
special event throughout the state uh
relative to ohrvs and the usage of
unregistered ohrvs
on private lands or on public lands it
needs to get a an event permit from Fish
and Game
there's many rules that go along with
that there's a a permit for which they
have to fill out it's a 45-day Windows a
fifty dollar fee that goes along with
that it's reviewed by myself
and then really vetted certainly they
have to notify the town they have to
notify which would in in you know within
that notification would be a permission
to operate
um you know under this permit in that
town so
um
they have to do all that I have to to
vet all of that and then they are issued
a permit like I said it's a 45-day
window that goes along with that it's
not um you know kind of a couple of guys
in the garage figure they want to have
an event on Saturday and and then you
know submit a permit
um there really is a lot that goes along
with that so
um right now the law allows for
unregistered vehicles to operate
um this would then and this come once
again comes from constituents uh asking
for different expanding events which
would be
um for uh just
usage for what happens a lot of the
times they'll say this is going to be a
closed course competition and then we
would like you know you may have an
exhaust that's over 96 decibels and they
could use it within their time frame of
that event
um another one is the Warren old home
day we get a a lot of uh or actually the
folks ask for an event permit to operate
during the hours of Darkness so they can
go so they can operate their utvs to the
uh fireworks
um so that's really the the um you know
what we're looking to do is expand that
um so that they would be actually able
to use that
um events uh once again
um one event where um whether they need
to get an event permit is
um the gun stock hill climbs or the hill
climbs during bike week that occur
um that would be one event
um so and really like I said the town
needs to be notified it is vetted
through this permit so it's looking to
really expand that to help these
different clubs
um you know with uh bringing these Ohr
the other part of the the event permit
the expansion that escaped me for a
moment was Operation on uh on public
Ways by permission of the the town
um and we would allowed to do that
through notification of the of the town
as well so I just wanted to hit on that
as
and I'll leave it out
that's all I have no good questions uh
why don't we uh any uh well first
let me break this up because really the
bill bill has two
uh important
issues and want to put the Montana plate
issue to bed is uh
quickly as possible well there's so any
disc is there any questions on the issue
with the Montana plates
they
representative LaMontagne thank you Mr
Tara and thank you for taking my
question I just want to clarify to see
that I understand it what you're saying
if they have the Montana plate
they can use it on the road but then
they can't use it on the trail
that's correct just not the Montana
plate but if any any if they were to
receive any registration uh for motor
vehicle use on a on a public way except
for a special commercial plate then yes
they could not register as an ohrv
represent representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um when when you say
um just just to be clear they they
couldn't use it on uh State
um manage Trails or um or
would it also somehow restrict them on
private trails
it would restrict them on both because
they would not be able to have an ohrv
registration on the vehicle
okay any other questions just be uh
or my edification right now
they they can go anywhere
on
our our roads and our trails
Montana plates and these are plates by
people not just from Montana but people
who own these plates they could be
actually being New Hampshire residents
maybe there's two questions there
I could certainly answer both thank you
for the question yes uh they right now
so what we are hearing is that it's
cheaper to get this Montana plate and
operate the three miles from their Camp
to the trailhead than it is to put it on
a trailer and take it down there and
that's really what it's looking to
circumvent so
um in the in the trail you know if the
town does not want their roads open
um it's really taking that away from
them so yes they they can currently
operate with that Montana plate from
wherever they come from
um with that Montana plate to go down
the road to get to the trail or to
operate wherever they want on a public
way
okay and we're not affecting the Montana
plate in any way because that's right
that's that would have to be a different
law actually with reciprocity I mean we
can't drive in mantana
that's correct the reciprocity is the
real issue it's um it's that this LLC is
being created for an individual they get
the Montana plate they put it on their
UTV which
um like I said his title is an off
Highway Recreation vehicle and they can
under reciprocity operate on the roads
so
um that to me uh was a Department of
Motor Vehicle issue and I've had those
discussions with them
um as of late I'm not sure that there's
a resolution to that but as far as you
know to help my my constituents and our
constituents out there this was really
Okay so
okay any other questions on plates okay
representative Kelly
thank you Captain Eastman um just to
talk about enforcement for a second so
someone We're not gonna be able to stop
anybody from having a Montana plate and
then going to the trailhead and taking
the plate off and and but so I guess the
point where he most likely to to catch
someone with this is if they had a ohrv
registration tag and it played driving
down the road so uh or do we have a way
to get this out to towns and cities so
that they uh are aware to look for dual
registration or
we would certainly look to educate
um you know the towns you know for for
this law um whether you know I I can't
really say if the town obviously or that
local law enforcement's up to them to to
do that um that enforcement
um has been an issue with the special
commercial plate as far as you know some
departments don't know what to do with
it so that really would come in
education and we're continuing to
educate on the special commercial plate
but we would certainly look to educate
everyone
um to speak about the to taking off of
the plate uh not uh really the the plate
that I see
um it's almost more like a sticker than
a than a plate so and the ohrv
registration says it has to be affixed
to the machine it can't be on a you know
a piece of Plexiglas that comes on and
off so it would be problematic for
any other questions on
seeing then let's go into the other
issue the uh issue on the uh
the up the off off Highway recreational
representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so this is really a
follow-up to my
earlier question about
um about access if I understand the
these events um the vehicles don't have
to be registered in the state
so they could potentially it seems to me
have
um this Montana plate because they don't
participate in this event they don't
need to be registered in New Hampshire
and then they're allowed to go on the
roads potentially with exhaust louder
the so the Montana plate would be I mean
certainly there could be a Montana plate
in the in the event
um
but it's really a separate issue
um the the event permit
um
you know for instance I've seen the
Montana plate out on the trail you know
in conjunction with a with a ohrv
registration the event
um really it's excludes the taking out
the Montana plate component is really
um more like a
you know it would be like a a water
Cross or like a mud another instance
would be like a Jericho during ATV Fest
in Berlin that would be an event where
uh you know those ATVs
um or our utvs are designed for just you
know doing mud events they're not going
to be driving down the road or you know
to get to the Irving station in Berlin
or anything like that it's more
um you know they're brought on a trailer
for that special event they are not
registered they're not ever going to be
operated you know on in that capacity on
the trail so therefore they need to get
an event permit to exclude that
registration
in conjunction with that they may also
have an exhaust
louder than 96 decibels so therefore it
it would be allow them to operate with
that as well so really the registration
um component of it and it's also goes to
the snowmobile side of it not that this
speaks to that but you know for instance
we get vintage
um on the snowmobile side events where
you know someone doesn't want to
register their snowmobile as an antique
so they they'll get an event permit and
be able to operate the trail system you
know and it's all and they'll show us a
map and things of that nature where
they're going to be so if you kind of
put that to the ATV side of it it could
be an antique ATV event where they you
know they just bring in their antique
you know the ATV three-wheeler whatever
the case may be and and want to do a
trail ride and then that's that's the
event
thank you yeah I think I understand that
uh the Montana plates do not all uh
allow the the
machined on the road
in violation of any of our of our uh
road laws
correct I mean French for instance
Montana plate doesn't allow to mean that
they can drive on the road on our
highways
with the 96. decibel plate or that 90s
with uh
remember the Montana plate and it can go
more than 90s I have more than 96
decibels
because that's a that's our road laws
right so they can't violate the road
loss they would have to adhere to the
road laws that's correct yes once it's
once it's operating on the roadway as a
as a motor vehicle it would have to
huh
representative Kelly
thank you Mr chair so I just think it's
important to reiterate um
that Japanese have you seen a a large
number of these Montana plates
um at this point in time or is this more
because we're starting to see this
activity now or we're starting to see
this Behavior now and we're trying to
get ahead of ahead of a wave or a
growing issue
so it's definitely growing
um the the first year uh I received
information that there was a group that
had traveled from Montana and were
actually stopped um and I believe it was
just outside of Colebrook
um by state trooper that saw these
vehicles that were on a portion of
roadway that was not open to ATV use and
that's kind of where we saw this Montana
plate and things started to
um where we first saw it I guess is the
best way to put it last year I started
having the groups from you know some of
the some of the towns up north saying
hey we're seeing more and more of this
um you know we're getting calls from
people saying why is this UTV operating
on a piece of roadway we haven't opened
it's on a state way they're not supposed
to be there and come to find out they're
operating under the Montana plate so
this is definitely a growing issue
um like I said all you have to do is go
online
um and register and register yourself or
get this LLC you pay your thousand
dollars or whatever it is and then
you're able to go and register this so
certainly like I said it's it's it's
I've seen one operating right here in in
Main Street
um in Concord and there's really nothing
you can do about it
um it's but yeah I think next year if
this doesn't pass we're gonna definitely
for a follow-up
yeah so just to read so right now we're
seeing just isolated incidents but we
are seeing growing Behavior so we're
trying to get ahead of ahead of the the
growing issue
thank you
representative power is there someone
else also
okay
Captain for taking my question I read
your testimony before the Senate and I
have some concerns about the waiver of
the 96 decibels can you speak to that
noise amount
um and what the position of the
really uh so 96 decibels is the is the
maximum decibel for a standard
um
ohrv exhaust to noise for to emit noise
while in operation in the state so
really what we were finding is that you
know folks were coming in and saying I
wanna I wanna apply for this
permit which is going to allow me to
operate unregistered and oh just because
I'm an honest person
probably this is like a 100 decibels
it's you know so can I get a waiver for
that and we would say no you we can't
because it only says in the law
unregistered we can't give you a waiver
for other things within the law
um so really that's what we're looking
that that's the instance that we were
finding is that people were coming in
and just being honest if they just came
in and said I want to be unregistered
they'd still be out there operating over
96 decibels
um you know at an event
um certainly if if they're operating on
a trail as a recreational vehicle and
you know and it's been modified or a lot
of the 96 we would certainly you know
take enforcement action on that but this
is really you know people were being
honest and and so that
they can continue to be honest we would
thank you thank you
representative veiled and represent then
representative
um thank you Mr chair representative
harb asked the question I was going to
uh how does uh ohrv if it has the
hundred decibels or higher
go back to 96 when they're just having
so
it's a couple it all depends on the ohrv
I guess some easier than others with
with dirt bikes for instance there's
spark arrested requirements um if they
remove spark arrestors which
gives some sort of more RPMs or
something like that I can't really speak
to it but there is a reasoning behind it
um
removing that would make the the machine
louder so that's an instance where they
could remove that operate in this permit
and then put it back on again we haven't
seen in the ohrv realm where there's
interchangeable exhausts certainly they
can you know remove them and it is
illegal to have a closed competition
exhaust which is used for closed
competition
um in the state period and we're not
looking to change that at all here or
give an exemption for that because it is
very very loud
um
in the snow machine world there's
definitely
um ways to where
um they've modified exhaust where
um all you have to do is pull two pins
on the exhaust and and your Trail
exhaust comes right out you put in your
little soda can exhaust that gives you a
few more RPM and and you're good to go
and and I've seen that in the field
where
um you know where people will say oh
yeah I didn't I forgot to put in my
trail exhaust that type of thing and
then they get a ticket for operating
with a loud machine so I haven't seen
that in the ohrv world it certainly
exists in the snow machine world I mean
it's probably only a matter of time
before that that is you know comes down
the pike but um you know really once
again this is this is just looking at
I'm not looking to expand 96 decibels on
the trails or anything of that nature
um you know or or any trails that are on
in in the towns that are open to ohrv
use this is really for those closed
competitions uh or closed events
um and and and for the town to say in
that notification process no we don't
want anything louder than 96 which would
be completely fine so if they said that
we wouldn't issue them a permit for it
so
I I guess if that's a kind of rambled on
but I hope that that answers the
just a small clarifying question thank
you for taking my question
it's just for events so if um these
events come into town they are louder
usually than 96. this isn't for making
all
any h-o-r-v
this is just for them to participate in
the event or in the competition for that
one-time
um
event
that's correct we're not looking to
expand any decibel levels or any of that
nature when when someone comes to us
with an event permit whether snowmobile
ohrv that they have to go through that
complete notification process of the the
town law enforcement whomever else the
butters that they need to contact
um you know I use the example of the the
hill climbs for bike week it only occurs
on bike week it's in gun stock and
certainly there are different events but
that's I think that's the best example
uh representative LaMontagne thank you
for taking my question
um
I'm just trying to understand so these
were the events they're most likely to
be unregistered because they wouldn't
normally pass registration for use in
the trails because they're louder and
they pollute more
is that correct I mean that's why the
language is in here to allow the use
of unregistered
I not necessarily because they're
by Design to pollute more or to be
louder that's that's kind of a only one
of many instances where somebody wants
an event permit
some of these
once again I'll use the the hill climbs
for gun stock
some of these machines they are not they
these people these folks don't would
never want to operate them on a trail
that they these are specific
you know machines for this specific
event
um you know in the instance of the
snowmobile side of it where they have an
antique
um trail ride this is where they they
they've really kind of cleaned up this
machine and it's there it's a vintage
machine and and they they have no desire
to kind of pound it across the trail
every weekend they just want to kind of
bring up these events it's like a
it would kind of be likened to uh a
classic car event where you know at some
of these they they they're not going to
drive them you know back and forth to
work every day they they want to polish
them up and show them off and and go for
a little ride and that that's about it
in the instance of the hill climbs
these bikes they don't look like
anything out there on the trail that we
would see they're they're made for going
up a mountain so
I have a follow-up question
but these events will be held on trails
and possibly
public roadways
designated during the event that's what
it looks like
this is saying
um I mean where would these events be
held if not on Trails or
that would really be up to the I mean
the event planner
um would come to us with the event
permit and say Obviously with prior to
getting notification to the town law
enforcement
um and you know for instance let's say
that the city of Concord wanted to have
a UTV parade on Main Street on Saturday
in July they would then the town would
say that that's okay we're gonna you
know we're gonna take we're gonna allow
that to happen they would have to take
all those steps or you know to make sure
it happened and then they would have to
come to us and say we're going to have
these this event on this road so
um you know that that would be a
possibility and that's why the public
way is in there you know if it and let's
you know it could be any Town saying yes
this could this could occur but it
really it's not just them coming to me
and asking for permission there's
there's really they need to notify and
and the permissions would start with
thank you Mr chair um thank you Captain
Eastman I'm trying to um just get a
idea about how many of these events
You're Expecting like just for this year
so when you're we're talking about
waving for events how many events are we
I thought I had the number of events
here and I don't see that I do
we do currently with snowmobile no HRV
it's less than
70 events a year
it really depends upon especially the
the winter events the snow machine
events on weather some of these events
especially in the last couple years
they'll certainly put an event permit
but they don't even occur because of ice
conditions aren't you know adequate or
or whatever the case may be I could even
see where you know there was excessive
rain and and you know an event gets shut
down on the ohrv side of things
um you know so
it's not thousands by any means it's
it's and I don't foresee that that
happening
representative Kelly and representative
Gould
representative Vale asked my first half
of my questions the second half is is do
you know how many so these are recur
these permits are good for 12 months
like some of them are recurring events
how many do you know how many of these
are recurring like what happened in 2021
also applied in 2022 versus new permit
applications in 2022 because I'm
guessing that for your department the
the recurring applications are easier to
deal with than the new set of
applications I'm just wondering if you
know how many like the growing you know
we're not seeing a lot of growth it is a
lot of the same
um you know
berry pond has in moultonborough uh
Milford three ponds they always have
events
um and there's events all over the state
problematic events they don't stay
around very long
um like there was one in Derry where a
gentlemen wanted to have a almost a
private event on on the pond and it it
the law enforcement had an issue with
parking and things of that nature so it
it petered out very very quickly I don't
I don't foresee a lot of growth in this
it's just you know certainly the folks
in Warren that want to operate you know
after hours to go see the fireworks that
would certainly be growth in an event
this permit it's July 1 to June 30th and
they pay 50 they list the dates and you
know
they could say well if it rains this
weekend we're going to have it on us all
in a date
so it's not like every weekend or
anything of that nature
thank you representative Gould
okay well sort of in relation to these
questions uh
the events that are being held are they
so the com the only one that I can think
of that had a complaint um was the one
in Dairy and what the issue was there is
this that was a snow machine event
um it was Big Island Pond it would spend
three years two three years ago now and
what happened was is that
um
they the individual had submitted a
permit well the year before he didn't
have a permit
um so then we had an officer go down and
issue him a ticket for not having an
event permit he then went through the
event permit process lied on the event
permit Dairy Police Department called
and said hey why did you get this guy a
permit and then we had to go to him and
say listen you signed this under unsworn
falsification saying that you had
notified all of these people that didn't
occur the permit was withdrawn and
the event did not occur so that's an
instance where you know we we had to go
back and and certainly vet some of this
stuff and and then you know remove the
permit so but that's the only instance
where I've had you know I've never had a
complaint from
you know Guilford residents about gun
stock kill climbs I've I've not had that
you know generally
um you know it like back Lake
um has had a couple of events in
Pittsburgh and we don't get complaints
about that the complaint I will take
that back the the and sorry it's a lot
more of the snow machine side than it is
the the ATV Side at this point
um
the the only complaint was on the back
leg in Pittsburgh was that the
individual had plowed a road which in
the area where the trail comes where the
Legal Trail comes out onto the lake and
that that the complaint was that could
have caused a potential uh issue with
nighttime operation so
what we did is that in the future events
we said you can have this permit but
there will be no plowing so if you're
going to have a you know a you know
basically a Raceway here it's going to
be whatever you know any disturbance to
the top of the of the lake is going to
be no plowing it's just going to be what
the snow machine occurs would naturally
occur so that's those are really the the
two complaints that come to mind and and
representative Kelly
and to follow up on that so it doesn't
happen often but you do have a process
for so if someone had a recurring event
permit you do have a process for
withdrawing the permit if there are so
someone had a nighttime monthly
nighttime riding permit and the first
one goes along and they have four times
as many people as they were expecting
and the town says no more we don't want
it anymore you do have a process for
removing that permit
um
if there was a if the town withdrew
consent
if we received a complaint from the town
we we would honor the town
um and say well we thought this was a
good idea but now it's not we don't want
this we can certainly we have the
ability to withdraw that permit
um and even if we we have not but if we
received complaints from a Butters or
something of that nature which we did in
this Dairy event so that's one of the
reasons why
um you know it was withdrawn and parking
issues and things of that nature and
that was the initial complaint the year
prior so
um yes we this is not you know set in
stone once it's signed by me it
certainly can be withdrawn
thank you
any other question representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thanks again for
taking my question captain
um just following up on this theme about
the number of events and the recurring
events
um can you qualify the number of events
where it's these these vintage cases you
know um maybe that you know the the
older machines that might be not have
the this same decibel ratings versus the
the larger events and also can you as
related to this how many events are
recurring events and and what's the
average duration of those recurrent
events
as I testified before a lot of these
events are are snow events
um so you know for instance
um
it's very predicated upon what the
conditions are so
um some of these events um over the
years they've
not occurred because we you know they
put it in July and maybe August hoping
that you know once December comes around
there'll be some good ice that doesn't
happen they might get off one event
throughout the whole season
um you know and that's December to you
know maybe the end of February possibly
into March but not really
um so it it's not like they're out there
every weekend it's really it's heavily
predicated upon the weather and so
um you know they can put in a lot of
days they do alternate dates just
because they they are working within
for a follow-up thank you um the part
about the the Vintage Vehicles versus
the um the sort of larger events do you
have a percentage of each
so we just made a change uh two years
ago as far as antique plates especially
on the snow side it used to be that only
residents could
could
register a vintage machine or an antique
machine and then that changed so that
non-residents could do that so as far as
the Vintage side that number has
definitely come down since then
um
but I I have not trying to think how
many vintage ATV rides I may have had
one in the last couple years
um I could certainly try to verify that
for you but I I off the top of my head
it was probably one event
thanks
question by anyone else
seeing none thank you very much thank
okay
Mr chair that's the honorable Suzanne
I'll get a phone call
I'm glad Captain Eastman answered all
the hard questions and warmed up the
seat so I'm ready to go uh for the
record I'm Suzanne Smith I am the uh
chair of the
House Bill 1188 commissioned to study
ohrv use in New Hampshire and I'm former
ranking member and former chair of this
committee too and it's really nice to
see old colleagues and meet new
colleagues
so um I the commission did not do the
commission kind of went to the Senate
quickly before the commission had a
chance to review it so I'm not here to
speak for or against the bill but I did
want to give the committee a little bit
of a background on ohrv bills because to
the best of my knowledge this is the
first ohrv bill you've had this session
in the past 23 years the use of ohrvs
has grown exponentially
not just in New Hampshire but around the
United States and resources has had many
public hearings on many bills and work
sessions and retainings and interim
studies and reintroduction of bills
throughout the years especially the last
five or six years many people have
testified pro and con on each of these
bills and we actually did pass some good
legislation related to the definitions
of what vehicles would be called
classifying speed limit clarifying speed
limits on the trails and on the roads
increasing fines to deter lawmakers and
this year in transportation they're
hearing a bill to better educate and
provide for better education and require
better education for not just people who
own their own ohrv and young people but
people who are renting ohrvs too
but there's less to be done because
there are as you can see and what I'm
hearing from the questions you've all
asked is between the ohrv enthusiasts
the butters law enforcement agencies
biologists and conservationists
everybody wants to do what's best for
the state some people just want to do
what's best for them but most people are
you know wanted to be for the public
good and that's what the commission is
trying to do review all these statutes
so because of all the ongoing issues
with ohrvs and their growth
um I introduced the house bill 1188 and
it is a long-term study commission and
our hope when we introduce that bill and
many of you signed on to that bill or
passed that bill helped to pass the bill
to bring everybody to the table the
commission has pretty much every
stakeholder you can imagine on it
there's 17 people and to check out and
figure out the best way to deal with the
laws and the rules pertaining to the
four-wheelers the three-wheelers the
dirt bikes and then this bill also
includes the bill we have before us
today has to do with um
snowmobiles also are events that happen
on the snow so the as Captain Eastman
explained the Montana plates which
actually it's not just Montana there's a
couple of other states that do it have
made it challenging in New Hampshire in
fact we heard testimony in our
commission that you know you can see
them driving down you see an ohrv
driving down Main Street in Concord and
you're like how can this be happening
you know and then you realize it's got a
motor vehicle plate so therefore we
can't keep them off the roads so this
bill will help that first part of this
bill which addresses these motor vehicle
plates on ohrvs which they're in Montana
they call Quadra Cycles because it
started off just being for dirt bikes
but now it's for they can they put any
ohrv under that category so if they're
not permitted to go on the trails here
in New Hampshire and that was a good
question representative Kelly had about
the can you double dip there and that's
an issue that commission will I'm sure
be addressing if it isn't addressed well
already in rules and statutes so it's a
that's a really good part of the bill
and I think
um
I wouldn't be stretching things to say
that I think the commission all agrees
on that one the second part addresses
the special events which you just had a
lot of questions about and heard a good
some good testimony from Captain Eastman
on
um and so already people buy these
permits and so already people are
allowed to be in these events if their
permit is approved if they have decibels
higher than 96
which is the law in New Hampshire 96 or
under and the um but what's different
about this is also and and these things
are happening there are night events but
that's written into the permit but this
gives the puts it into statute so that
it's not a jumping through hoops for
fish and game to approve these events
whether they're happening during the day
or at night and whether there's a few
Vehicles
as was explained to me some of the
vehicles are not uh rail bikes they're
only used for competitions and for these
events
but event also in despite all of this
there were some concerns expressed in
commission and concerns that I have that
make me to how when I testified in the
body across the way
um I said that I thought the bill was a
little premature because we didn't
really thoroughly vet it in the
commission and I know I'm being selfish
saying the commission can do everything
but um that's kind of how I feel but um
there is concern about disruption to
Wildlife especially in the winter
because as Captain Eastman said a lot of
these events are in the winter so when
you have
um Wildlife that are used to you know
they're in a neighborhood where there's
always traffic or they have to cross the
interstate they're kind of used to that
ongoing problem for them but when it's a
formerly really quiet place and there
would be a huge loud bunch of noises one
night it kind of throws them off their
game and Wildlife are pretty desperate
to keep all their calories on and having
to use up more energy than they need to
in the winter that can be a problem for
them
um Butters people whose homes are near
where the events are taking place could
be affected by the loud noises of the
decibels and the bright lights
especially at night and one of the bills
we
the one of the concerns I have also is
for racing races on ice
which on Ice there are no speed limits
and so there could be an organized right
Ice Race of motorcycles
um
in during the winter and you've got the
butters around whatever Pond or lake it
is
having to deal with it and most almost
all the ice surfaces in the state
because ice is water and water is public
Trust
it is there are no speed limits on the
water
um so anyway the because of the time
constraints of the 2023 session the
commission as I said did not have time
to thoroughly vet the legislation when
it was in the Senate so we're not making
a stand and saying you need to pass this
or you need to kill this but um I you
are the resources Recreation and
development committee and ohrvs are an
important part of resources natural
resources uh Recreation of the for the
public and economic development because
these ohrvs do bring money into the
state so I hope you'll work hard and
consider everything you've heard today
and do your best on all the ohrv bills
because I'll bet next year you'll have
more of them and thank you and if you
questions for the uh honorable
representative Smith
thank you Mr chair and and thank you
honorable it's so good to see you
um I have a question you said the
commission hadn't had the opportunity to
review this bill yet to render an
opinion uh do you anticipate that they
would within the next month or so we
have reviewed it but there are so many
interests there are so many issues just
in any legislation as you know once you
start digging in you find out there's
more and more to learn on the subject so
we didn't come to any no one felt when I
asked did we want to take a vote nobody
really spoke up so I would say that we
just felt like we needed more time
because every time you open one door
there's another door two or three
choices to make to figure out what to do
about something
so that I don't think in a month because
we don't have another meeting until the
first of June okay follow-up Mr chair
um but I think
um correct me if I'm wrong but I thought
I heard you say that the commission was
generally in favor of the first part of
the bill regarding the registration I'm
going out on a limb and that was my
personal opinion oh that the commission
would feel that way because I didn't
hear anyone complaining about it when we
were you know meeting and talking about
everyone was pretty much aghast that
this could happen okay with the Montana
and representative Farm
representative welcome back thank you
um
I know the commission hasn't made a
decision but I highly respect your
opinion personally and I know you and I
have been through all sorts of ohrv
pills with noise and lakes and and
motorcycle racing what do you think of
um I'm kind of in the middle I can't I
can't really I can't really say because
I don't
I feel like I still don't know
everything even today sitting here and
listening to the testimony I was even
saying oh I didn't realize that oh I
didn't realize that so I mean I don't
feel that I'm there yet to make a final
representative Donnelly then
representative Gould
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question do we know roughly
the revenue stream that these events May
bring into New Hampshire
that I have no idea about but I'm sure
Captain Eastman may know the answer to
that and and anytime you're talking
about a special event if it's in a
community
um there's the adjunct money that comes
in from people going to restaurants or
being on the Parade route and shopping
and things like that but Captain Eastman
may know that better than I do or even
director Rennie from the trails Bureau
and yeah I think that would be the best
answer thank you
sorry
representative Gould well uh thank you
oh thank you my question
um
I don't know if this is the time for
this or not but would it be
something we could do to eliminate the
second part that seems to be more of the
concerned
that's up to the committee okay listen I
don't know that's our job not my job
representative Kelly
Miss Smith would you mind um just
detailing the members of the hb1188
committee just for those who are
unfamiliar with it just they understand
the diverse horses we're bringing to the
also I was going to send you all the
link we do have a website and any
materials that are given to us go up on
okay uh let's see we have chair renzulos
on the commission uh representative
Kelly's on the commission Michael
Eastman from Fish and Game and he's in
enforcement Daniel Bhutto from
representing Municipal police
departments Christopher Vetter from
State Police
New Hampshire Municipal Association has
a representative New Hampshire auto
dealers who are also the dealers for
ohrvs the New Hampshire rail trail
Coalition North Country Council
representing in a butter
house Transportation committee has a
member which I it was just appointed
yesterday so I don't quite have her name
um and um let's see Craig Randy who's
the Bureau of trails director for at
dncr
D.O.T has a representative the NH off
highway vehicle association has a
representatives and representing uh
landowners
and appointed by the Timberland owners
and the Farm Bureau then we have
um representing conservation uh
interests and then I am representing the
New Hampshire Association of
conservation commissions
thank you
and then yeah any other questions
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
thank you um for taking my question
um has the commission heard of other
concerns from community members like do
you is there is there a public forum for
uh for discussion or um and other
concerns specifically about events
we have not been soliciting from I mean
anyone who wants to talk about the
events should be here today
um and we are still in the very
beginning we've only had three or four
meetings thus far we're meeting every
other month for two hours and so we are
going to we've got four years left so
we've still got time to do that we'll be
hearing from various factions the
Butters and
what we've been hearing from law
enforcement thus far working addressing
the safety issues first and the
enforcement and how thing how the laws
can be enforced and we tried to get some
of that underway before we got into this
thank you for your question
any other questions by members of the
committee
seeing none
thank you very much thank you very much
and thanks for everyone's attention and
questions
chair calls Rich Parsons representing
the New Hampshire off Highway Vehicle
Association
good morning chair renzullo and members
of the committee my name is Rich Parsons
I work at ryp Granite strategies here in
Concord and I represent the New
Hampshire off Highway Vehicle
Association
um we are here today in support of this
bill we represent about 25 or HIV clubs
throughout the state
um fishing game when they kind of
brought forward these ideas last year we
thought they made a lot of sense
obviously the Montana plate you've heard
a lot about Montana came up with a very
clever way to try and get revenue for
their state you know they make it very
easy for you to be able to create an LLC
go online and get one of these Montana
plates that also comes with a sticker
that lets you use it on the Montana
Trails there you can do it from anywhere
in the United States you don't have to
be in Montana to do it so they have
certainly made probably a good deal of
profit from from doing this by you know
letting you make it road legal as a
quadricycle under their law which allows
you to operate it on roads
I won't spend much time on that because
it sounds like most people understand
that part and there's some general
consensus that we should stop that the
event permit part of the bill I guess
I'll talk a little bit more about I know
representative Donnelly you had a
question about
um how many people come to some of these
events and I in Revenue so I looked up
um the gun stock Hill Climb you know
they're this year is their 100th Annual
Ride and last year they had 6 000
spectators at the rod so I don't know
exactly how much revenue but just that's
the amount of people that it's bringing
in and I think
um you know it's important to note that
the event permit application that fish
and game has is is very detailed and I
encourage everyone to look it up you can
find it online pretty easily
um and you you have to notify or you
have to list all the towns that would be
impacted that you've notified them you
have to give assurance that you've
notified all landowners give their
information their names you have to do a
detailed a map of where the trails are
going to be
so that they can see exactly where this
event will impact and I think also
important to note you have to do it at
least 45 days before an event at least
so that gives fishing game enough time
to call these these towns make sure that
they are okay with this see if there's
going to be a Butters that might be
impacted see other other things that may
happen and they're already doing this
for a lot of these events obviously this
is just adding a couple of flexibilities
for them in the law and so we're just we
trust that fish and game will do what is
right you know we think it's very
important and we're very sensitive to
landowner rights we rely extremely
heavily on landowners for our trail
system in the North Country there have
been issues in the past certainly that
we want to put behind us and that I
think fish and game is very much aware
and sensitive to you know a Butters and
towns that do allow this to make sure
that you know there isn't blowback
because the blowback isn't good for
snowmobilers it's not good for ohrv
communities in any sense so we we fully
trust that the event permit process
that's in place now is robust and that
fishing game will make the right
decisions on some of these and you know
I think some of these that things that
they're being allowed like on the hill
climb or something you know you have a
lot of folks coming in from out of state
with their vehicles and you know I think
it gives a little bit of flexibility
where maybe there's gray area now in
terms of the event operators tell
everyone you can't have something with
over 96 decibels whatnot but someone
comes in with a dirt bike that
goes over that and they're going up the
hill or something that you know
um kind of gets rid of the gray area a
little bit to to allow it if needed
um so with that I'll certainly take any
questions folks might have
any questions from the members of the
committee
oh and then Darby thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question can you
just give me an example maybe of
um an event that would require that that
your group supports that would require
each of these
um you know new exemptions public ways
louder than 90 successibles and um uh
writing after hours
is so I don't have one on the exhaust
higher than 96 decibels
um I think
I think there's obviously a lot of these
events are done in the winter maybe you
know
race cars on ice or something like that
there's some of those kind of events but
our group I don't really have an example
of that in terms of on public roadways
or half hour between sunset or not I
think
um Captain Eastman used the example of a
Warren in terms of being able to ride
your UTV down to watch the fireworks
show and be able to then drive it back
thank you
anyone else
saying no one else
Abby Evangel
um
hello my name is Abby ivanko from quorum
even though I live a mile away from the
ATV trail ATV's wrapping up the trail
has become the soundtrack to my home in
the woods
and my friends and neighbors who live
even closer to the misplaced ATV trails
obviously have it even worse
sections one and two of SB 160 deserve
your support
but please strike section three which
will allow as you know louder and later
ohrv events Section 3 weakens the ohrv
laws that were carefully written over 20
years ago with input from all
stakeholders to protect the people and
the lands of New Hampshire from the All
Too Well documented disturbance of
off-road recreational vehicles I can
tell you there are plenty of complaints
people don't know who to call because no
matter who they call they don't get
relief they call the town they call Fish
and Game they call the State Police and
then they give up calling because the
disturbance just goes on so
uh there are plenty complaints and every
event at Jericho leaks into
neighborhoods in Gorham Berlin Milan and
Beyond
the inclusion of public ways in Section
3 is extremely disturbing to the
countless tax paying residents of Gorham
Berlin Milan Pittsburgh Stratford
Columbia Henniker and Beyond so many of
these residents have been asking to have
the laws and protections strengthened
and restored not weakened so they can
reclaim their once peaceful
neighborhoods from the noisy Dusty ohrv
trails that they've turned into
where is the fish and game that would
actually the fish and game build they
would actually address these voluminous
constituent complaints and restore the
peace and quiet lost ohrvs
Section 3 is out of step with fish and
games Mission as Guardians of the states
Fish Wildlife and Marine Resources
working to conserve manage and protect
100 decibels doesn't fit in any habitat
if passed for just a fifth for just a
fifty dollar permit fee a promoter can
host a louder later ohrv event on state
lands
why not have it on public lands the 50
permit fee even allows recurring events
so potentially every weekend of a season
can have these louder later events and
of the 50 fee all of seven dollars and
fifty cents goes to law enforcement
Fish and Game fish and game law
enforcement is already stretched too
thin for at least the last eight years
the executive director of fish and game
has stated in his annual ohre report
that his officers are having trouble
meeting quote constituent demands for
adequate enforcement control coverage
and constituent complaints end quote
for context of how the vast majority of
New Hampshire residents and visitors
actually enjoy our beautiful Outdoors
please note that fish and games sells
over four times the number of fishing
licenses as it does ohrv registrations
that's over four times for every one
ohrv there are four fishing fishermen
Fisher women and they like to do that in
peace and quiet and the noise of these
ohrvs does not stay in the event
Corridor or the trail Corridor it goes
um the the outdoor Foundation has
collects National Data and the top five
outdoor recreational Trends are hiking
camping fishing running and cycling
not motorized
in recognition of these documented
Recreation Trends and the voluminous
complaints the Decades of con the
Decades of constituent complaints about
ohrv disturbances and land degradation
please remove Section 3 from SB 160.
please strengthen the public protections
of RSA 215a and please restore the
previously gutted protections for our
citizens and our lands
I have a short video clip of the gun
stock Hill Climb I don't know if any of
you are familiar with it but you can
Google it
and uh and you can see what and here
Maybe
[Music]
wow
here we go
and I don't know if you can see the dust
I haven't slept in two days
[Music]
so the um the the louder events um you
know for the for the fireworks Gorham
has fireworks
the people who live along the trail and
are affected by this
they finally get peace at nightfall and
then for a special event it's later so
they can't so the the Riders keep
roaring by till 10 o'clock and of course
after hours
and there are so many ways to get to
fireworks without an off-road vehicle on
our roads and trails
thank you for your time
any questions by members of the
committee
representative Kelly
I'd like to thank you for coming down
all the way from Gorham this morning I
know it was a long ride with the snow
and everything so um
the uh
yeah no flurries we had some nice snow
flurries this morning so
um I just I'd just like to ask you if
you you know based on your uh testimony
I think I know the answer but but do you
believe that the impacts of oh HRV use
are disparate or are evenly spread
throughout the community or do they
affect more some certain members more
than others and then do you feel that
that we as the state are doing enough to
a few people are bearing the burden of
these Trails you know no one
wants to be surrounded by 96 decibel
vehicles
from half an hour before Sunrise to half
an hour after sunset from May 23rd to
November 1st
it's just it's inhumane it's uncivilized
and if more people knew or the right
people were Disturbed it wouldn't be
happening but it's picking and choosing
which neighbors neighborhoods that are
collateral damage and paying all the
did I answer your question
yes thank you and the the other thing is
um the laws in co-ops are different
so you have more protections living in
other counties than the citizens of coas
and Grafton do so there's not even equal
protection under the law in New
Hampshire
thank you chairman and thank you for
your testimony
um were you aware that gun stock
mountain resort is actually County Land
and that those gun stock hill climbs are
sanctioned by the public body of the gun
stock area commissioners
thank you
um I wasn't aware of the specifics no I
just know that the uh the officials in
koas are not speaking for the Butters
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um so I remember when we first started
with the ohrv build in 2018 and I'm glad
to see that you're still here working
really hard with legislators and the
other stakeholders in order to come to
some resolutions
at the time I had heard about when I
first came in in
transportation in 2018 that there were
quite a few neighbors that were
disturbed by ohrv use up in the north
country and so I did some research and I
found a bill that changed some of the
environmental regulations that was able
that enabled us to build ride the Wilds
if I'm correct
um
so this has been a long road and you are
here with just a couple of supporters
where are the people who used to come in
at the very beginning when we started
looking at regulating some of these
activities
um they're exhausted they're tired
they're at home they're taking care of
their elderly parents their disabled
children
um
they've spoken out for years and gotten
no relief
they're writing in
or or moved away
that was my follow-up do you how many
people have had to leave the uh the area
from that advocacy group
well I know of at least three people in
Gorham who have moved away
driven Away by the ohrvs and uh my
friend in Pittsburgh she's lost most of
and I should point out that these
taxpayers pay thousands of dollars in
tax taxes but we don't have a state
department representing us
when we don't have a paid lobbyist
either
-up and actually
um I think you just answered my question
any questions from any members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you for your time
uh it's County Cork and County Career
thank you thank you uh for taking my
testimony my name is Catherine corkery I
am representing New Hampshire Sierra
Club and uh our motto is to explore no
Enjoy explore and protect and I
represent uh 14 or 15 000 people in the
state
um
I want to Echo what with the testimony
that we just heard
um about uh section three but uh before
I get there I do support the
reciprocosity aspects of section one and
two I believe yeah um
and and part of that is reflected in our
opposition to section three and that is
um the operation on the public ways for
special events
um
it is
when you're not expecting these ATVs and
ohrvs on the roadways and a special
event comes it's rather shocking to see
the the these these vehicles on on the
road uh while you're driving I'm going
pretty fast
um on the road
um so
having these special events which
uh our annual or
not annual uh for vintage vehicles or
not vintage vehicles for competition
vehicles or not competition vehicles
seeing them on the roadway is shocking
and
um
and having them louder not only at the
event but driving through your
neighborhood is shocking
um and I I would ask
um I I actually wanted some
clarification because it seemed as
though that some of these events would
allow for operation well after sunset
um and in the bill as I read it and
maybe I'm missing something maybe
there's something further in the rules
it said that the operation would be a
half an hour after Sunset and a half an
hour before sunrise
so that means no operation a half an
hour after Sunset but
fireworks usually end well after Sunset
so I'm I'm a little confused by that
piece
um
uh and
um my last question what what was that
I'm sorry I wrote them down
um
oh uh we had in the past we did support
the commission and I think
um
maybe section three isn't ready for
prime time yet and and uh it might be
appropriate to allow the commission
to spend some time with this idea of
expanding the permits
um and and have some further thought on
that uh and with that I'll conclude my
any questions
representative Kelly uh thank you chair
I'll just clear up that that
clarification so the half hour before
Sunset to have our side so by by Statute
my understanding by Statute they are
automatically blocked from that period
of time so this like that's what it's
saying that the the permit could allow
them to operate During the period uh the
nighttime period okay okay thank you for
that I'm sure you're not the only one so
just to clear that up thank you
got it
anyone else thank you
thank you very much
seeing no other cards
we'll
declare the hearing
closed
that's that's what happens when you
yeah which I might gavel
underneath here leave it in your drawer
lock it in your little girl somebody
will steal it but you can lock it
there's a lock oh yeah that's true
actually I don't know actually I got
them in your wallet
yeah but that's not I don't I don't have
a key that I just did a drawers in there
yeah there's a little key I I know but I
don't I got it
exactly
you know normally if they want to steal
oh ah
missed call yeah potential spam
[Music]
Chairman's daughter
that's right
yeah right I'm ordering pretzels for
them
all right
okay
what's up
foreign meeting to order on how Senate
bill
senate senate Bill 164 FN relative to
consideration of biodiversity in the
land and Community Heritage investment
program
chair recognizes Senator David Waters
Senator the uh thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee nice to see you
all again I'm Senator David Waters
District Four to introduce Senate Bill
164 relative to consideration of
biodiversity in the land and Community
Heritage investment
program
um
you know
the bill itself in terms of what it
amends in State Statute is is fairly
simple if you look on the second page
here
um
under the land and Community Heritage
investment program you'll see the list
of things that are eligible resources
and a criteria by which they are
evaluated and you'll see what it's doing
here is adding biodiverse
areas to the other kinds of things and
considerations that can be used in this
land conservation land conservation
program
um so but I'd like to back up from there
as to why this is a useful tool for
l-chip and potentially other areas of
state that the government that deal with
land conservation to be able to consider
biodiversity
and um so the pre the reasons for this
are related to the kind of evolution of
our understanding of how our environment
works and how our ecological systems
work
you know you look back 20 30 40 years 50
years ago under President Nixon and the
first efforts that we had to preserve
endangered species and wetlands and so
forth that tend to be focused on that
endangered species we have lists of them
State endangered federally endangered
and we have certain protections for them
that deal with the environment the
habitats that they're in and then of
course when all the concerns about water
resources and wanting to preserve
wetlands and other kind of special areas
that those two that became a focus of a
lot of a lot of legislation so you see
kind of an evolution there
and then we began to use words like you
know ecological and environmental to try
to have some understanding of just what
we're getting at that is a value in
keeping our landscape healthy for New
Hampshire and for future Generations so
over the last 20 30 years the concept of
biodiversity has emerged as one that
addresses the larger the larger picture
in some very useful ways and that's why
you have this definition at the bottom
of
on page one and two which is the kind of
standard operating definition that's
being used as a you know large
International
body 192 Nations that are working on
biodiversity conventions and guidelines
that countries can come together to work
on in individual Nations can use some
guidances as well
um so biodiversity then you'll see the
comprehensiveness here means all the
species including plants bacteria
animals and humans in a particular
region habitat or ecosystem they work
together to maintain balance and support
life
includes variability within those
species it gets down into the kind of
very roots of life in the you know
genetic phenotypical phylogenic
functional attributes
distribution over place and time
I just want to point out a couple of
things one that it is very comprehensive
and understanding if you want a healthy
environment you've got to have all these
components of a healthy but for me I
think a really important thing here is
notice
um in the first line there uh last time
I checked humans are animals right and
it recognizes that humans are part of
biodiversity what's interesting to me
about that is we kind of used to think
about you set aside land and you kind of
basically keep people off or you know
imagine that you can conserve something
in a pristine Wilderness condition but
it's pretty clear now it's very hard to
find a place on Earth
or in the oceans that has not been
impacted by human presence right so it
kind of makes on you know that we ought
to comprehensively understand what is
the impact of humans in these
environments as well and to come to
understand that and I think that it's
very interesting evolution of our
understanding that you know biodiversity
is everywhere and we're everywhere and
the impacts of humans are everywhere so
this is a useful book there
now let me back into I want to come back
to that definition in a minute um but
let me back into
um the findings here which as you know
don't become part of Statute but they
offer some kind of explanatory reason
for why this is
important two things that are noticed in
the finding first species loss
and then secondly the loss of
populations and the figures there are
rather staggering that there is a 69
percent
loss of populations of animal and this
is you know it's a variable over place
but it's pretty much confirmed in terms
of the num the populations in a lot of
uh species in New Hampshire
um
and then uh the alteration of
environments
um you know I do a lot of work on you
know microplastics and pfas and all
those things and you bet you can find
evidence of alteration of an environment
in very various ways
um and then secondly starting on uh line
um I think some pretty core principles
that you know what are we most value
about New Hampshire why do we The
Landmark weeks act back in 1911 why did
New Hampshire Take the Lead National
this because we recognize that for New
Hampshire what counts as a healthy a
healthy and clean environment I mean
that's that's why people are here and
and don't want to make sure that our our
children can have a healthy and clean
environment as as well and that you know
as our It also says you know that our
state
certainly many branches of our state are
in the business of making sure we have a
healthy and clean environment that is
useful for hunters Hunters Fishers
hikers
um
biosystem resources like clean water and
and so forth so you see I've kind of
backed into you know why biodiversity
and what we look at it and what it means
for the potential threats to America uh
New Hampshire's environment and then
also the value of biodiverse environment
let me come back to the definition I
know we're going to hear from some folks
that if we're putting this in statute
that maybe we ought to work on this
language
um a little bit and uh I understand that
I think that um you know for me what was
important in this bill was having
somewhere in statute a definition of
biodiversity and I suspect that in the
future it'll become useful to more areas
of state government but let's get that
definition right so I said this is the
kind of standard one that is being used
by government agencies and and so and
and so forth um but you know maybe uh
we're going to hear from some of our
folks that uh this might need a little
bit of work
I thought I mentioned one last thing
um one way that a lot of us have
probably have heard about biodiversity
is the commitment to preserve you know
30 by 30 30 percent of New Hampshire of
uh the country's
um Land and Water Resources by the year
2030.
um and this is a national initiative and
an international one as well uh and and
you can understand how that that has
become a vehicle
um if you go online and look at some of
those things for suggesting that we need
to protect biodiverse areas in terms of
that 30 by 30 you know Hampshire's kind
of there already so it's an aspirational
goal but you look at all the land that's
under conservation here and how we're
handling our Water Resources we're
pretty good on 30 by 30 but I just
thought I'd mention it because that is
that's something that you you know you
come out from this from New Hampshire
and come out a little bit and you look
at this you'll see that people are
talking about that as well so Mr
chairman once again more than three
minutes but uh thank you for your
Indulgence not a so any questions uh
comments by people from the
representative rung
and representative beloved thank you Mr
chairman and thank you senator for
taking my question
um this bill was this bill was amended
by in the Senate
um can you explain
um the background of what what changed
what uh was made with through the
amendment
everything
I was afraid something look the original
bill
I thought to myself okay if we're going
to do biodiversity let's do it
everywhere and uh I had gone through
statute and everywhere I saw some
preservation or Municipal preservation
of land I said let's put biodiversity in
there I also um look pretty closely at
the ways in which you know biodiversity
which potential recognition of
you know uh if we if we valued
biodiversity what kind of protections do
they have and I was looking at animals
and you know private action to protect
your animals and private action to
protect your land so
um that bill
um was the trial balloon that came down
pretty hard
um and came back to to this which I
think does the essentials it lets us
talk about biodiversity and why that's
valuable and provides a useful tool for
one program so
um that's the way legislation goes and I
think the wisdom of the Senate there was
and the agencies was very helpful in
directing Senator Waters back to Earth
foreign
thank you Senator I I've been there I've
had lead balloons too
um now I think you kind of touched upon
this but the definition of biodiversity
that's online 26 of page one did is
there a source that you you got that
I I wish I had it on in my tip I have if
you'd search this online you will find
um uh
you know various National
um entities that work on biological
diversity and this has been going on for
decades and this is the kind of
definition is offered as a guideline
um I I participated in United Nations
convention
of the parties and biodiversity up in
Montreal where an international 192
countries came up with a custom General
guidelines and this is not their
definition but it's it's in the ballpark
okay so I wanted to put something here
that seemed to be the kind of accepted
parameters of it and I've kind of tried
out on the parameters it's every all the
all of the species
and the inclusion of humans
that's that's the core of all the
definitions and that's what you got here
is that I love it thank you Mr chair uh
Senator Waters did you mention an act
that was passed in New Hampshire in 1911
I hope I think of the date right it's
the weeks act that's what it's called
yeah I mean hasn't actually created it
created the White Mountain National
Forest I mean it's a national it's a
federal act but a derived from here
and the impetus is kind of interesting
because
um there was massive logging up north
big fires
and as with the Adirondacks it became
recognized that these these places were
sponges and if we wanted to have a clean
water supply for the rest of your state
you'd better offer some protection so
the weeks act um established the
principle of uh you know established the
White Mountain National Forest and set
the pattern for subsequent ones as well
and I mean that's that's why we have the
beautiful Northern Forest we have
because that biodiversity was preserved
um
go New Hampshire
any other questions by
I'm thank you Mr chair thank you senator
I taught biology at Plymouth state for
quite a few years
um but I retired about
15 years ago
by training I'm a marine psychologist
that means that I study seaweed
seaweed is not a plant it's an Elga
the five kingdoms of living things
seems to me
to not be fair
um and I think that fungiology should be
included in that definition yeah
um it that's just my opinion I'm just
asking you know could we look into this
a little further and
Maybe
figure out whether those can be added or
not
thank you for your question and um you
can tell me now I was thinking you know
I was looking back at the language of
the bill and it says biodiversity
includes the variability among living
organisms from all sources including
terrestrial marine and other Aquatic you
know so um what we have here
um and then you'll see in line 30
including variations so that that line
down there is not meant to be exclusive
you see what I'm saying those are very
much yeah huge pieces of our
biodiversity yeah yeah people who live
on the Seacoast
probably would agree that seaweed
ought to be included in here that's very
important I mean I have Marine in here
but in in this and then including I mean
you could add something there but the
question I was going to ask is that is
fungi a living organism or not
yes okay good I was a little confused so
if you think there's some clarification
addition here of course I the language
is meant to be incorporated and
inclusive but if it needs more thank you
representative you got to go in to the
chair with these questions yeah excuse
me Mr chair
yeah we're in a hearing you go
I don't usually have questions I know I
know
but then but that's if you want to
continue you can but you continue
any other question representative harp
thank you Mr chair and thank you Senator
um on some of your other bills you
always I think my memory says you used
to mention who asked you to bring this I
didn't say any notes Here did somebody
ask you to bring this bill up or is this
just your bill
it's time to blame it's all me as I said
I have been I've been working on um
biodiversity environmental issues you
know for for
the last 14 years I've been in the
legislature 15 years
um and uh particularly issues related to
Wildlife corridors habitat strongholds
I'm on the Linux marine fisheries
commission representative New Hampshire
gregonian fishies from Maine to Florida
so
um this is something that as I became
aware of the national conversations
around biodiversity I tried to put
that's it thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question Senator
um
I I appreciate the definitions um in the
you know in in basically the l-chip um
uh sex portion of the bill but I wonder
if
um it's enough because as I read um as I
read through this that you know 227 M
which describes LG the section that
seems to me that you're most trying to
affect is I think is the guidelines for
um how out chip properties are
um evaluated and 227 M9 specifically is
provide some guidance there and I don't
see this this build doesn't amend uh 227
M9 I'm wondering if it should to meet
your goals
well thank you you know we have the
director of um l-chip coming up the
reason I chose this is because
eligible resources okay that that was
that to me was the the place to put this
because this is where eligible resource
gets to find that then they can act on
so that's why it's here but
I hear what you're saying thank you
thank you
is it biodiversity
like Beauty
or
in other words it's in the eye of the
beholder
uh yeah
we
how do you I mean having this is a
definition is
not complete
because you've just heard that the uh
that there's there are other things that
can be added yeah
yeah but also the uh even if even if you
added them they might not be complete
simply because
diversity is a is a concept that
for in each individual
uh
yeah
I don't believe that and keeping
diversity is not necessarily concept
that for each individual I pref I don't
I don't want to keep smallpox around if
we can get rid of it
there's things of that nature so
use China if ins instill in the in in a
statue
the uh just personal Concepts
uh is that really what we're here for
but that's
thanks for the I think there are a
couple questions there Mr chairman and
um thank you for them and I'll answer it
um you know if you think about the
language that we do use in statute
currently we've got words like ecology
we've got words like environment
and I think those are very amorphous
words but they have been functional in
statute for a long time
I think biodiversity actually has the
benefit of being
um
more particular
because
we are working towards a definition
which includes just with that what does
biodiversity mean
the bio part
and the diversity part
that's why the definition is here and
that's why it's important but it's only
important not because it reflects one
person but because it reflects a
consensus among many scientific
organizations conservation folks
and so forth
um
and because it can be used it can be
useful it can help guide people as they
evaluate land and the issues that it
faces and how you conserve it
now do note that you know is that we do
this as you know just kind of your
second question about it um and I don't
really particularly like coronavirus
either you know so
my mom had Polio you know and uh yeah
that kind of biodiversity we're not too
keen on
um
but note that the the definition does
not
require any action
it enables some action
in terms of what l-chip will do in this
bill
but that's what we do as legislators is
that we have definitions and then we
consider how they should be wisely
enacted for the use by our agencies and
for our our public so
um I think it I think it uh it makes
sense it'll be useful it's a good tool
and um if we need to keep working on a
definition before people are comfortable
with using it then so be it that's what
the legislative process is too
any other questions by uh members of the
board
Sarah thank you yes thank you chairman
and thank you Senator waters for your
testimony can you expound on a little
bit here in the methodology SEC
methodology section
it says this bill also creates a form
contract to preserve the rights of
domestic animals and wild animals can
you explain that a little bit um that
means thank you for your question
um that is not relevant to the bill as
amended
the the bill is introduced had some
things about animals the bill is amended
has nothing to do with that so I I just
if you if you if you call up the bill as
amended you won't find out language
anymore so but thanks thanks for
yeah I should have mentioned that
earlier so my apologies any other
none
thank you very much thank you very much
and you have a very biodiverse committee
I don't know I didn't realize
Republicans and democrats for species
goodness
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Paula Belmore I'm
the executive director of The Landing
Community Heritage investment program
and on behalf of the board of directors
I thank you for allowing me to come here
to speak to SB 164.
since 2000 El chip has been working hand
in hand with New Hampshire's land
conservation Community to protect our
most important natural resources today
l-chip funds have helped conserve more
than 237 thousand acres of land across
New Hampshire ensuring their Perpetual
contribution to sustaining the
ecological Integrity of our natural
environment
as we understand it this bill seeks to
highlight the value in preserving a
healthy level of biodiversity in New
Hampshire
we applaud the Bill's sponsors for
recognizing this important goal and
agree that preserving biodiversity at
levels sufficient to support healthy
resilient and sustainable ecosystems
over time is Paramount
their efforts to place biodiversity
preservation at the Forefront of natural
resource conservation efforts in New
Hampshire are commendable
as amended by the Senate SB 164 seeks to
insert a definition of biodiversity
into the l-chip statute it also seeks to
include biodiversity as a type of
conservation easement and add biodiverse
areas to our list of eligible resources
for funding
while acknowledging the importance of
this complex issue we are concerned that
the bill is proposed could create
confusion within the l-chip statute and
therefore around the larger issue
defining biodiversity within the l-chip
statute is appropriate but only if the
term is used elsewhere within the
statute however establishing a statutory
definition for a concept as complex as
biodiversity requires careful
consideration at this time the l-chip
board has not had sufficient time to
fully consider the wording proposed
the insertion of including biodiversity
as a type of easement in the l-chip
statute also creates significant
confusion within that sentence depending
on how that language is interpreted it
either splits conservation from a list
of easements or it introduces
biodiversity easements as a subtype of
conservation easements this could have
negative impacts that are presumably not
the intent of the bill
conservation easements are a very well
established mechanism for preserving
land in perpetuity conservation easement
terms are tailored to achieve specific
conservation purposes that are
appropriate for the land being protected
for example the preservation of habitats
that support and sustain healthy levels
of biodiversity could very well be a
conservation purpose stated within an
easement and the associated restrictions
of that easement would be tied to that
purpose
thus conservation easements are already
well positioned and well used to help
preserve healthy biodiversity
I'm unfamiliar with a type of easement a
particular type of easement known as a
biodiversity easement and I cannot
comment on how those would be used in
the state
as proposed the bill also defines
biodiversity but then it uses the
undefined term biodiverse areas to
describe the types of land that would be
eligible for l-chip funding
biodiversity by definition is an
attribute or more accurately a series of
attributes which can be measured and
which together help to describe a region
habitat or ecosystem
measuring the degree of biodiversity
that exists requires analysis of several
different properties these may include
the number of species present in an area
the distribution pattern of individual
organisms among the species present the
relationship between those species or
the distribution of ecosystem types
within the area
we know that highly biodiverse areas are
likely more resilient and better able to
remain stable over time despite external
stressors
but the degree of biodiversity in a
defined area must also be considered
within the context of the greater
landscape a 100 Acre property may
present with a very low degree of
biodiversity if if considered in
isolation but when considered as part of
a greater biological region that
property's critical habitat for example
Open Fields Rocky ridges or Wetlands may
very well support species or ecosystem
diversity that is present in the larger
area
in that case land that might be
considered having low biodiversity on
its own couldn't very well be a vital
component of a biological biological
region
well the use of the term biodiverse
areas in plain everyday language or
conversation is generally understood to
refer to highly biodiverse areas when it
is used as the bill proposes it refers
back to that definition and the plain
language meaning is no longer valid the
intent becomes confused we believe that
developing language that qualifies
ecologically significant lands a
resource already included in the l-chip
statute and eligible for funding could
more explicitly convey the intent of
this bill in summary l-chip recognizes
both the complexity and importance of
biodiversity preservation in New
Hampshire and we support efforts to
maintain a healthy level of biodiversity
in our state
l-chip would welcome an opportunity to
engage with the sponsors and other
interested parties and stakeholders to
address these concerns should that be
the will of the committee I'm happy to
any questions by members of the
committee
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I am looking at the language in the
bill and wondering
would it satisfy your concerns if the
biodiverse areas in
section four on the third pair or the
second page I guess if that were
replaced by something like areas that
promote or protect biodiversity so
they're referred directly back to the
definition
thank you for your question
I think that the the key point that I'd
like to make is that biodiversity exists
it exists in a field it exists in larger
tracts of land the question we're really
evaluating is to what degree is it
highly biodiverse or not and so by
including a definition of biodiversity
that that is accurate that biodiversity
is this mix of species Etc
and then saying we want to protect
biodiverse areas we're essentially
saying we want to protect everything
because every area is biodiverse to some
degree so we really need to go a little
bit deeper and look at what needs to be
preserved in order to to to maintain a
healthy level of biodiversity in the
state or in a biological region so it
becomes much more complicated I did
think that representative Darby's was
representative suggested that section 9
might be an appropriate place
to consider this was I wish I thought of
it myself
we are already considering biodiversity
in every Grant round in almost all of
our natural resource proposals there is
a question about resource significance
that the answer to which is usually tied
to biodiversity to some degree or
another so this is already happening at
l-chip and it has been happening for you
know 23 years
we have studies on the state that help
us to measure biodiversity and and help
us evaluate which properties are more
important to that end our conservation
easements often relate to biodiversity
so this it's already happening
my concern would be that this language
give me a follow-up
thank you
um that's really helpful thank you and I
think I know the answer this question
but I just want to ask it explicitly to
make sure that I'm not misreading
so we were looking at the old
methodology I think is attached still to
the bill for how a fiscal note was made
and I don't see
um l-chip explicitly anywhere here and I
just wanted to make sure if we were to
pass this bill as is if you have a sense
of whether it would make a fiscal impact
on your work it sounds like maybe not
because you're already doing it but you
answer thank you for the question no
you're absolutely correct because we are
already undertaking evaluations of
properties based on biodiversity levels
it would make no impact on our program
at all
oh
thank you
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
so I mean
I've listened to your testimony I'm
trying to figure out does l-chip support
this bill or oppose this bill as it's
being introduced to this committee the
l-chip board is neutral because it won't
have an impact on the way we are
operating the program there's not a
concern but there is some
question about how much time they've had
to consider that definition it's very
complex and I think that representative
Baldwin raised some good points I have
heard concerns about insects and how
representation there and once we
introduce a statutory definition it can
also be linked to in the future and so
what what are the impacts of that I
think it's important and I think the
board feels it's important we get it
right if we're going to put it in okay
representative Darcy thank you thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question
um you mentioned that you're already uh
evaluating
um or incorporating studies I think or
listening to studies about biodiversity
could you describe um briefly
um how those are conducted and how
um how you get inputs on um
you get the words you use but
um the resource the protection of
resources sure thank you
um I will not pretend to be able to
explain the methodology behind the
studies but for example The Nature
Conservancy is resilient landscape study
is often used and that measures any
number of things to help us determine
which properties are necessary to allow
species to be resilient in the face of
external stressors to move appropriately
so that's one example
um and I could certainly get you some
others that's exactly what I was looking
um fishing game
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm Dan Bergeron I'm the chief
of the wildlife division for the New
Hampshire Fish and Game department I'm
here in opposition of SB 164.
um I'll keep this I'll try and keep this
brief because we share a lot of the same
concerns
um that Paula highlighted from l-chip
there
um one of the concerns is that the
definition is very broad
we currently when we can serve land we
also currently work to preserve either
Wildlife diversity diverse habitats we
work through our Wildlife action plan
we've done analysis of the state and the
different habitat types and the species
to try and identify species that are at
risk or species of greatest conservation
concern we highlight those habitats in
the state that we look to protect but
our focus is mainly again wildlife and
habitat diversity which in the broad
scheme of things gets at biodiversity
but with fairly specific goals in mind
um again the concern would be this broad
definition
in in-state law if that could be linked
and to the Chairman's point that
not necessarily that it's in the eye of
the beholder but different groups may
have a different impression of what's
the most important part of biodiversity
um for us you know our main concern is
habitat diversity and Wildlife diversity
but again when you have bacteria genetic
variability humans are all part of this
definition
it creates and introduces I think
confusion in in some ambiguity and we
see that it could potentially create
issues in the future if if again it were
linked if other rsas were linked to this
specific definition because of its
broadness so we share a lot of the same
concerns about that definition and and
its potential to have impacts in the
future a lot of these things can be very
difficult to measure
um
um so
representative Kelly
thank you um so I'm I'm seeing that dncr
has a natural heritage Bureau that has a
list of plants and animal species does
that does their work of compiling that
list like does that how does that
translate into your office like does
that information reach you or is that
just kept over there as information yeah
no so so that that that information does
reach us
um within the natural heritage bureaus
um within their their databases they
also will keep records of rare rare and
threatened species as well so we work
closely with natural heritage Bureau
when we do environmental review
um we we see those that information as
well so we work closely with them on
that information
not thank you very much thank you very
much
Kurt Ehrenberg
um
thank you uh I'm Kurt aaronberg I'm the
state director for New Hampshire of the
Humane Society of the United States here
at its support
of uh the amended bill
um
you know we are we represent all the
animals in the state of New Hampshire
and my interest here is the health and
well-being of the animals of the state
and I believe this bill
uh furthers those interests which is why
I support it we're happy to work
with anyone and everyone to uh
make sure there is a work workable piece
of legislation and I want to thank
Senator waters for his foresight working
on these issues
I'll take any questions
any questions by members of the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
foreign
good afternoon thank you Mr chairman uh
I am Matt Leahy I'm the public policy
director for the four Society we are a
Statewide land trust and Forestry
organization and
um I just I won't repeat what Paula
mentioned but
um you know we certainly would support
the idea of
um you know giving this bill more
attention
um you know to further it you know we
are the forested idea is is neutral on
the bill because quite frankly we're not
sure if it necessarily changes you know
how we operate and we are you know we do
protect land
um you know I would point out that
when you look at what's driving the loss
of species whether it's plant or animals
or the whole range of life out there the
biggest driver is the loss of habitat or
the degradation of existing habitat and
that is something which not just the
four Society but I think
or really all conservation organizations
and public agencies fish and game for
example is really one of the certainly
one of the key Partners in New Hampshire
in advancing the protection of land so I
think if you know again if there are
ways to
really make sure that we're getting it
right and to help Advance
um you know the mission of the state
agencies and you know private
organizations conservation commissions
who are who are doing this work we again
would you know like be part of those
conversations as well and I would just
say and I know this is not the
focus of the bill
but you know ultimately what is going to
protect our these really important areas
is you know resources for the
organizations that are doing this work
and yeah certainly fish and game and
dncr
um you know l-chip is is one of the Key
Programs to do this so again I
understand this is not the focus of this
bill but I I do think it should be a
consideration going forward is that you
know if the legislature legislature
determines that
um you know more needs to be done to
protect biodiversity you know I think
you know additional resources at some
point again the fish and game department
does a lot of work in this area
um and you know they are really
a key to this so but I'll have to take
any questions
any questions for uh by anybody in the
committee
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um do you have in the um
for a society do you happen to have a
definition of biodiversity that you work
with
uh no but that's a very good question I
mean what we do if we're going to do a
land protection project we do consult
with
um again fish and game they have their
Wildlife action plan
um the uh the uh
um
Heritage Bureau at dncr you know has you
know inventory of of the different
species plants Etc that are in a
particular area so we consult you know
with our state agency partners to
basically find out what's there
um and you know if there are maybe
important resources that
um you know make the particular parcel
in question you know more important or
more valuable
I mean I I have honestly I've seen a
very uh simple definition
um about
biodiversity but it's not I mean we
don't necessarily rely on a definition
we really rely on what's on the ground
when we decide whether or not to protect
yeah
any other questions
any other questions by members of the
committee
representative Kelly
thank you I'm trying to figure out the
best way to word this so from a forestry
perspective we New Hampshire doesn't
seem to have much plantain uh Plantation
uh forestry and I'm wondering if from a
from your public policy background if
you have any thoughts about what if we
have things in a law that prevent that
right now or if that's just because of
the there's no market for it
you mean for uh Forest plantations yeah
like cutting down a forest and replacing
it all with Southern yellow pine or
something like they would do down south
yeah
[Music]
um
I mean well of course we you know we do
have the tree farm program so but it's
not the same thing
um and I don't honestly know
um
that's a good question I'm sure I can
give you a direct answer on that but I
mean it's it's never been a
um
you know focus of land managers land
owners you know loggers Foresters to to
do that type of
operation in New Hampshire
okay yeah thank you if you think of
anything after you can just send it okay
any other questions I have maybe it's an
observation I've
sitting here really thinking and
what's what's what's going on
isn't
isn't this uh well
isn't the biggest
uh adversary of biodiversity
Mother Nature itself
considering the fact that from beginning
of time or the beginning of Life on this
Earth
things have come and things have gone
and this was long before man yeah I'm
doing anything
are we just trying to freeze something
in place yeah well thanks to the
question so I mean it is true that
throughout history you know species have
gone extinct through you know natural
functions you know they just couldn't
compete but the the issue and concern
now is the the rate at which this is
happening
um and so that
is being generated by again the loss of
habitat or the degradation of habitat
you know the introduction of invasive
plants and pests
um is another driving force and of
course uh pollution you know especially
a water resources so there are things
happening which you know go beyond what
Mother Nature intends and really what's
with
anyone else who wishes to speak from the
audience
that
want to meet for a few minutes just not
on you know uh well it's
you know just
yeah you want to take next week off what
schedule the next week right so
I could uh we could we could have uh
work sessions because work sessions
don't have to appear in the calendar